nujs is a progressive JavaScript
framework for building user interfaces
on the web it makes it very easy to
create server rendered applications
static websites and single page
applications and it's a popular choice
for developers looking to build fast and
scalable web applications Gom created
this course about Nu 3 he has 10 years
experience as a developer and is a
popular instructor on udemy let's start
learning hello everybody and welcome to
this course about n free my name is Gam
and today I'm really excited to
introduce you to my favorite framework
next is a framework made on vgs and you
might know that last year VJs upgraded
to the version three so n did the same
and now we have all the features of n
free with n gs you can create full stack
application and it's a very interesting
framework because there are several
rendering mode during this course we are
going to learn everything you need to
know to create a full stack application
with next here is the program of our
course we are going to learn first how
to create an application then we are
going to look at pages and rooting the
fight system that help us to create
Roots
automatically we will look at components
and the main feature of next is to
autoimport the components how to create
layouts how to deal with images and
assets we are going to look also at
composer the new feature of view free
how to create plugins and why how to
deal with middle Wares to prevent
authentification for
instance we are going to learn what are
modules a specification of nuggs that
help us to supercharge our application
we are going to talk also about State
Management and especially about
Pia one of the most interesting part of
this course is talking about the
rendering mode with ssrw air and ibrid
mode the new
mode finally we are going to look at
servers with Nitro how to create a
server on our app we will need also to
know what are use fetch use lazy fetch
use Asing data those methods provided by
n free to fetch data also if you are
interested to work with n you might be
interested also in SE and metas for the
rendering modes we will look at life
cycle hooks how to configure our project
then finally we will finish our course
on next content a package or module that
help us to create static website with
next and finally we will create a full
stack application which will be a
documentation and an API so if you are
ready to follow this course let's
go no GS is a JavaScript framework made
to create from end application next GS
has been built on top of vgs a bit like
next GS for react and there's a lot of
features that help us to develop faster
and that improve our developer
experience so when you go on n.com the
official
documentation we see now that we are on
the version three of next because yes
view switched recently to the version
three so next had to update its latest
version so when we click on get started
we arrive on the introduction page but
for us we are going to go directly on
installation and we are going to go down
and here we see that we have a command
npx Nuy init project name so I'm going
to copy paste that go into my terminal
I'm going to give a name so it's going
to be my next project and there we go my
project has been installed the first
thing we can notice when we arrive in
this next project and if you already did
some vgs before is that it's it's really
light there's only six uh file at first
so when we are going to type npm install
we're going to have our node modules
however we don't have the folders that
we have on viewfree for instance on view
free we got the source folder we can
have the public and assets okay with
next it works a bit the same however the
difference is that we will not have any
Source folder at first we will have to
create our own folders page component
etc etc and it's going to work like this
is because next is providing to us a
file rooting system that works on the um
organization of our folders it will
automatically create Our Roots and
another thing that is really cool is
that with n gs it's going to autoimport
our component so we will not have to
import all of this but we are going to
see that in the next lesson type npm
install to npm install our project then
we are going to type npm run Dev to Just
Launch it in your in our browser and to
look at it at first okay this is done
and the first thing we can notice is
that we have a node module folder and we
also have this point next folder y Dev
or npm run Dev it depends and here I'm
going to open my local 3000 and there we
go we've got our application running
which is actually this next welcome only
so our application is now set up we can
use it directly like this if you want it
you can deploy it from now it will work
um as it's supposed to work and what
we're going to do at first is just to
remove this and put hello next threee
because we don't need that uh component
all right our app has been created but
it's totally empty the first thing I'm
going to do is to add a bit of
configuration because yes with n gs we
have a N.C config do typescript or
JavaScript file that can help us to
provide some configuration so we have a
method called um Define next config that
receive an object and in this object we
can pass several elements um the topic
of this course is not to talk about the
configuration the topic of this course
is just to create an app however I'm
going to do a bit of configuration at
first before we start the course in
order to follow every step so the first
thing I'm going to add it's an alas this
alas will help me actually to catch some
elements directly from the Source but
you are going to say to me gam you
talked before about uh the autoimport
feature autoimport is working for pages
and component and some other folders but
not necessarily for everything so we
will necessarily need an alas so this
alas will be an at okay and here I'm
going to say hey I need the path of my
current uh project and I want to be at
the rout so I'm going to import uh
resolve from
pass up there all right and here I'm
going to resolve a pass so I'm going to
start with de name and here it's going
to be just the uh uh the source the root
actually of my source okay so now when
I'm going to type at everywhere in my
app it will resolve directly the de name
so the de name which is actually the the
root of my folder and I will be able to
uh catch anything and to import
dynamically uh every element of my
project another thing is that I want to
add a CSS file because we don't have any
style in there so what I'm going to do
I'm going to create a folder directly
which will be assets and in this assets
I will add a main do CSS if you want to
have a CSS it's okay me personally I'm
going to have a CSS what I need to do
now is to install SAS because SAS is not
installed so I'm going to type npm
install SAS and I'm going to launch
again the project and what I want to do
I want that this main. CSS file would be
actually root stylesheet of my project
so what I can do is to type CSS and CSS
actually it's an array so I'm going to
specify on this next. config Ts that I
want to have one file as a CSS root file
you can have many other because it's an
array so here I'm going to add assets
main. scss to uh check if it's working
I'm going to add a body and here it's
going to be color red and when I get
back there we go we see that I have the
color red apply so it is working it is
applying my scss finally for the need of
this course I'm going to install
Tailwind CSS so I go on Tailwind CSS on
get started then I click on framework
guides there I click on next GS and I go
on the version free because here we are
on the version two so here we arrived
there and we see that we have to install
Tern CSS in our terminal so I'm going to
copy paste this going back there I'm
going to stop npm install Tailwind CSS
there we go then I need to um init my
file so I'm going to type npx Tailwind
CSS in it then we need to specify to N.C
config.js to use post CSS and Tailwind
so I'm going to copy paste this and I
get back there and just after my
configuration I'm going to add post CSS
plugins etc etc all right then finally
what I need to do also it's to add
actually to the uh Tailwind config.js
right now which is almost empty it's to
add here um the content file that I need
to watch so let's have a look on this
I'm just going to copy paste and we're
going to look at it we will watch for
components so there will be a components
folder we will watch for layouts because
they can be a layouts folder also page
Pages which will be the pages of our
project plugins but also for the next.
config dots and of course the app. view
so now it's done what we need to do is
to add those elements Tailwind base
component and utilities to our main.
scss and we already imported it to our
project remember just up there on the
CSS line there so when I get down it's
telling us to do it but we already did
it and now let's run again our project
and let's see if it's going to work and
when I get back to local 3000 there we
go I think it's working because the font
has changed and if I go to the network
on main. scss we see that Tailwind is
clearly imported if you want to get this
start a project you can go on my GitHub
and down there you got the next free
Tailwind starter and when you click on
it you have the full repository
available that you you can clone
directly finally we are ready to follow
this course and to learn how to create a
front-end application with next
free one of the main features of next is
its file system routing what does it
mean basically in view free you are
supposed to install view rter to deal
with rooting then you will have to
create a root. GS file declare your root
import your component or pages and then
organize all the nested Roots uh the
navigation guard etc etc with NS you
don't need to do that because there's a
system inside n that helps you to deal
with the routing automatically and it's
working with the Pages directory so we
see here on the official documentation
that every view file inside the Pages
directory creates a corresponding
URL so let's get back to to our app and
let's try to create a rout so I'm going
to create a new folder called
pages and inside these Pages I'm going
to create for instance an event events.
view page so here it's supposed to be
slash events as a corresponding URL so
I'm going to create a quick template and
in this template I'm going to type div
events page all right it's good but
remember in my hub. viw I have this and
normally with view rter if you already
coded with view you're supposed to use
um the router view buil-in component
that is provided by
view how does it work with next well if
we go back to our app we already got an
error and if we try to access the page
events we have actually the page of app.
view and this is a bit confusing because
um we supposed to have events page and
we finally have h. view it's really easy
to understand we have to say to next to
use the routa so first we are going to
use a first buil-in component which is
next layout because later we are going
to use the layout of next and inside
this next layout we are going to use the
router view buil-in component but
actually it's not router view it's next
page next page here is working exactly
like router view components with view
router now I've did that I can get back
and on my slash events Roots I got the
events page here display however if I
get back to the root of my app I got a
404 and it's totally simple to
understand I don't get any index at the
root of pages however h. view is
supposed to be the root of our single
page application and it needs the first
page to start and and this first page
has to be index. view inside my pages uh
folder so I'm going to type template div
and I'm going to say here index page
simply so I got an index. view which is
the first page so the root URL of my
application then I got slash events that
is displayed there so when I get back
and I update so maybe I got to start
again my server for him to understand
that I have an index page right now and
there we go I got my index page display
and if I get to/ events I got my events
page all right so it's really cool let's
try to create a new page and let's say
that it's going to be my and uh my and
dash profile. view okay and here I'm
going just to copy paste the code that I
have there I'm going to close all of
this and I'm going to type my profile
see that it's also working how cool is
that okay let's remove this my profile.
view and let's create uh instead of
events. viw a folder called uh events
and now we've got a problem because we
got this event. viw and events folder
there so what we can do is to move this
events. view here and I can rename this
as index. viw so now what is it
happening is that here when I go to
events it taking my index. view and
let's say that I want to create a um a
file inside my events folder which
relate to another route is that possible
yes it's possible and it's going to
create the full URL for us so let's say
that we've got an event and here I'm
going to have a profile. view the
profile of the event let's say so I'm
going to have a template tag div Profile
Event there I'm going to save and when I
get back and I type slash profile okay
because I'm in the evance folder and
there we go we access to the profile
event page how cool is that it's amazing
because we can create a lot of roots
like this and of course if I wanted to
create a new folder called profile and
inside I would like to add a new view
and which will be index inside it could
work so you see you can create really
nested roots and with this file rooting
system inside Pages next will totally
understand what you are trying to do and
will build for you all the path that you
need let's say now that in event I would
like to have a an ID actually that I
would catch through my rout you can do
that with brackets so here I'm going to
type ID between
brackets. view exactly like we would do
in vuejs so I'm going to type template
there and I'm going to typee div and
actually I'm going to have event ID and
here of course I would open My Double
curly brackets and inside I would try to
access to my root params doid exactly
like I would do in VJs okay this dollar
root is the object related to the
current root and here we're going to
catch the ID between the curly bracket
between the brackets sorry that we got
in our view file when I go to the page
event ID 12 for instance there we go we
catch 12 as an element uh provided into
the params okay it could be anything it
could be a very long number it could be
a Gom for instance whatever there we go
we can catch it this way so when you
want to make Dynamic Roots you can use
those brackets and put inside the
parameter that you want to catch and
it's going to pass immediately through
the root this parameter for you now if
you want to catch this parameter inside
your script so here I'm going to open a
script with next we got Auto Import
everywhere so here we got available a
method called use root so I'm going to
create a new variable and here I'm going
to use root the method uh that help me
to uh access to the root so I'm going to
console log this root and I'm going to
get back open my console and what we see
is that we got the root as a proxy
object what I can do is to type root do
params exactly what I would do inside my
template and here there we go we see
that it catch actually the ID of my root
so I get root. params do ID and this
method use root is available everywhere
in the N application and you will see
when we get more deep into the course
everywhere in the N application you have
a lot of methods like this that are Auto
imported everywhere you need them you
earn a lot of time by doing this this is
a good timing to show you another method
that is very useful provided by next
exactly like next GS if you know xgs you
have the context available n also got a
context that is available what you can
use actually is the use n app function
here I'm going to remove this I'm going
to type cons next is equal to use next
app use next app is actually a function
that is available everywhere in the
application
to give us access to the current context
so here I'm going to console log next
I'm going to get back I'm going to
update and look at that we've got an
object which is big and contains a lot
of method and data and if we look a bit
closer to it we see that we got access
to what we call a context this is
actually the context of your current
application so here you got a function
called use head we're going to see that
later we got had view app that give us
access to all our View application with
the instance etc etc and all of these o
etc etc will help us to deal with some
operation everywhere in the application
when we need to and on the official
documentation we've got a good
definition of what is usn app use nuk
app is a buil-in
composable that provides a way to access
shared runtime context of next which is
available on both client and server side
it helps you to access the view instance
app runtime HS runtime config variable
and internal State such as SSR context
and payload use n app will be very
useful when you will create your own n
application you may need this context
very very often don't forget about it
let's finish now to talk about the
navigation if I get back to my app. view
here let's say that I want to create a
header and here is going to be a header
with a list okay of elements so here I'm
going to have a list and inside this
list I would like to have a link that
pushes to the homepage what I can use is
next link okay and next link actually uh
it's a built-in component that helps you
to push to the rout that you want so
here I want to push to home so I'm going
to type slash and here it's going to be
home okay and then let's say that I want
to push to events okay so I'm going to
type SL events when I get back here up
there I got two buttons so now it
appears like a text but when I click on
home I go on home then I click on events
I go on events okay so use next link
when you want to create a link that push
to a route and when you want to create
actually some uh programmatic navigation
as you see next is providing to us a
very easy system to deal with the roots
we don't need to create a root folder we
don't need to to import another package
or another plugin to our application to
deal with rooting next itself is build
around this file rooting system and
later you will need to deal with the
authentication and deal with what we
call middleware if you need to prevent
the entry on on a page depending on the
authentification for instance what you
will need to do is to watch the course
about middleware because within within
this next context actually we can deal
with with middleware that prevent some
actions depending on the user interface
and depending on the user entry
URL it's time to talk about the
components with next three we get a
feature called autoimport which
basically means that every component are
available everywhere in the application
because it's Auto imported so if we look
at the documentation it's written that
most component are reusable piece of
user interface okay and you can create
these components in the components
directory and they will be automatically
available across your application
without having to explicitly import them
so previously on uh vgs what we were
supposed to do is to every time we need
the component to import it everywhere we
need it we can also go on the main. GS
file and say actually to The View
application to use the component and we
can import it everywhere also it's a
kind of Auto Import however with next we
don't need to do all of this and that's
really amazing because we save a lot of
time so we are going to create a uh
folder and here I'm going to close all
of this we're going to create a folder
uh called components okay components and
here inside this folder I'm going to
create a first component called alert.
view okay and this component is
basically taking a div this is an alert
uh component okay I'm going to add some
style to it so it's going to be a BG uh
green 500 it's going to be rounded px2
py1 and text y there we go and maybe a
bit of margin buttom all right we've got
this component and right now now we've
got our up running there an index page I
put the the background in Black to have
a bit of more effect and now I want to
use this component alert in my index
page so I go on my index page and what
we used to do before is to go to script
and then we would say basically import
alert from blah blah blah we don't need
to do that anymore we can directly say
hey here I want my component
alert let's get back to the app and
suddenly we've got our component
available and that's that's amazing
that's why I love n with n we save time
so how does it work basically it work
like exactly pages with the file routing
system it's based on the name of the
file and it's based on the level of the
current file so if I create another
component let's say that it's going to
be header. View and here I'm going to
type this setup and I'm going to put
header here if I go to my app. view and
on top of that I'm going to type header
because it's the name of the file what's
going to happen is that it's going to
look for header as a component as the
file coming from the folder component so
you have to create this folder component
to tell next hey um I'm looking for a
component and this component is supposed
to be in the component folder so the
component directory is playing a very
important role in the next application
it's just the the the place where you're
going to put all your interface pieces
so if we want to create a deeper
component tree actually what we could do
here is to create for instance let's
create a folder and profile and in there
what I can do is to type also index.
View I'm going to type profile component
I'm going to close all of this and get
back into my index. view and down there
I'm going to type profile and when I'm
going to type profile here it will
understand that he has to look for the
profile and here he found a folder and
then index. view so he understand that
it is the profile component let's say
that in my profile component I have
another folder and this folder would be
header again so we would have an index
view there and again it's going to be
profile header how can I import this
header here inside my index what you
have got to do is to come from the
parent to the children so with got
profile at first so I'm I'm going to
type profile then I'm going to type
header because my component is supposed
to be in the header folder so from
component I want to look to profile then
I want to look to header and inside
header I got this index. view so I'm
going to type profile header and if I
get back to the app there we go it is
working I got my profile header so to
give a deeper understanding of it I'm
going to say that here it's going to be
uh the main page now I'm going to open
my console and inside my console I'm
going to inspect and look at this I got
a first div which is ID next and inside
of it I got the root of my application
and what do I got I got a div called
header we already uh imported it but we
didn't put the class header so if I go
there and I put the class header we will
understand that this is the header we
are talking about okay header and then
we got the main page because remember in
app we got the header then we supposed
to have the current page display so
we've got actually Main and then we've
got our alert so we didn't put alert but
if I go there and I put alert it will
work this way Aller there we go so we
got the Aller component then we got the
profile and then we got the profile
header so you can go really deep like
this you can go really deep by creating
component this way and let's say that in
my header I would have an avatar.
view okay here I'm going to put class
and again here on on on vs code I got
the pass profile header Avatar it really
helped me to create my current component
so it's going to be profile header
Avatar and actually it's going to be
Avatar of profile header I'm going to
save and now I want to import this
Avatar inside my profile what can I do
well actually
it it works exactly the same everywhere
depending on where you are you just need
to always start by the component rout so
here what is the component I want to
import the component I want to
import it's avatar from header from
profile so I need to start by profile
then I need to look to header then I
need to look to
Avatar and this is the component that
has been created
previously I went to profile then header
then Avatar and I've created this
profile header Avatar and when I get
back to the app there we go I got my uh
profile Avatar just after inside the
profile header it's a bit confusing when
you got a lot of files like this if I go
to my index page which supposed to have
profile and I remove this I got nothing
and if I want to use the Avatar that is
in the profile header Avatar what I can
type it's always the same I can always
import all those elements depending on
their root in this example I made in
purpose something complicated I created
several folders with several files
inside because I wanted to show you that
you can go from a simple organization to
a complicated organization and to to
retrieve actually the pass of the
component because you are not importing
them anymore and you are using the
autoimport feature of next you will need
to understand how to catch those levels
and the easiest way as I said to you is
to come from the parent than going to
the children until the element you want
to catch what we notice with next three
and components it's that this system
help us to not importing everywhere our
components and it give us also the
ability to um call components everywhere
we want dynamically however be safe when
you are creating your components
architecture try to be simple try to be
easy do not create really deep folder
and deep files because otherwise you
will have very long name at the end if
we get back there for instance we got a
profile header Avatar it's a very long
name okay you don't want at the end to
have very very long name because the
readability and the developer per
experience will decrease so this system
is good next uh made something great
with this Auto Import however be careful
on the
usage sometimes in our application we
want to have separate design or we want
to change the behavior of our app
depending on the authentication for
instance if we are logged in or log out
for that we can use what we call layouts
and of course n gs help us to deal with
layouts so right now I got my main page
and if I get back I just got this page
here index. viw that is created and it's
totally empty and let's say that I want
to create first a default layout for
this page what I'm going to do is first
I'm going to create a layout folder
inside this layout I'm going to create
by default default. viw default view
it's going to be the layout by default
and we will see later that in our page
we will be able to declare what layout
we want to use depending on uh the
situation depending on what layout you
want to display actually so here I'm
going to create a template and in this
template I'm just going to create a
first div and this div is going to be
class and I'm going to call that default
layout this way okay just for the
example then what I'm going to write is
just a p and I'm going to type default
layout so we will see that we are in the
default
layout what I need to do now is to
specify that here I want to put the data
I want to put the pages I want to just
display the current Vision on uh what I
want to display so I need to use the
built-in component slot slot here with
receive actually our page which is
index. there so once I have done this
let's get back to my up let's refresh
and there we go we see that without um
writing anything on my index. view I got
this default layout that is display and
if I open my um uh here my elements
there my console I got the default
layout that is apply and we see that the
page is a child of the default layout
all right so we created our first layout
and if I apply some class like for
instance text White BG uh slate 900 and
H screen for this one we will see that
my style will be apply on the whole
layout so on all the children down there
so to create a layout you use slot all
right now let's try to create another
layout which will be a custom one so
here in layout I type custom. view and
actually what I can do is just copy
pasting this custom layout and instead
I'm going to call it custom layout and
here is going to be custom layout again
we need the buil-in component slot in
order to display the content we want to
display so now I've got this I want to
create another page because default is
for all the pages that are not uh asking
for any other layout but now I'm going
to create another page and let's say
that this one will be for instance
custom. View exactly the same name as
the layout but you're not obliged it
could be events or whatever okay so now
we set this we have to create another
page so I'm just going to grab this one
it's going to be custom page and here
I'm going to type custom page all right
the thing is now if I go on SL custom so
with my router you know that it
generated the root if I go on SL custom
what is going to happen on the custom
page I got my default layout
and this is normal because I didn't
specify any layout to use when you want
to specify a layout to use in your
script here you are going to say that
you want to use this layout on this
custom page all right so what you need
to use as a method is the Define page
meta Define page meta is a function
available everywhere in your n
application that you can call to specify
y uh some parameters because it's an
object that is taken as a parameter and
here I'm going to use layout and in
there I'm going to use the name of the
layout that I'm going to use so you
understood now that I want to use
custom okay I specified here on the
custom. viw page that I want to use the
custom
layout now I'm going to close all of
this and just open here my custom. view
now now let's get back to the page and
let's see if we got our custom layout so
when I get back I got finally my custom
layout so back in the layout I'm going
to change just the color let's say that
we going to have a background blue there
we go I got the background blue now I'm
going to get back on the main page and
we see now that I switch from a layout
to another one so if I get back to
custom there we go we've got another
layout so you understand now that we can
use this layouts folder and we can
create new layout inside this folder
they will be automatically registered
with the name and after in the pages you
will be able to call this layout through
the defin page meta
method when you want to store sty sheets
images or font you usually use the
assets
folder but with next we got two
directories that can handle these assets
these two directories are public and of
course assets previously we created an
assets directory to put our main. scss
but me I added two images there to show
you how we can use assets to fetch our
images but first let's have a quick look
on the documentation and let's have an
explanation on different between public
and assets the public directory content
is served at the server route as is the
assets directory contains by convention
every assets that you want the build
tool V web pack to process so what is
the difference between public and assets
that's the main question here why do we
get two different folders and that's
maybe why you are watching this video
because it's a bit confusing to have two
different uh folder that we could use
actually to store our images font or etc
etc let's start by explaining the assets
directory let's have a look on the
documentation next use is vit or webpack
to build and bundle your application
this is the tool that basically bundle
your app the main function of this build
tools is to process Javascript file but
they can be extended through plug-in for
vits or loaders for web pack to process
other kind of assets like stylesheet
font or SVG this step transform the
original file mainly for performance or
caching purpose so it is clear that the
asset directory is processing an
additional step to your stylesheet to
your image at the bundle actually so
here this step is improving the
performance or of our files and also
it's working on caching by convention
nuk uses the asset directory to store
this file but there is no autoscan
functionality for this directory and you
can use any other name for it which
means that n is not watching at assets
it's just a fixed a static repository
there that is here just for the dev and
there is no Autos scan functionality so
it means that no is not watching to it
so you you can name it the name you want
here basically it's assets let's take an
example here I got my app running and in
assets I added two images so what I can
do is to go on my main page which is
index all right and here in index what I
could do is to import this image so I
can take this example down there and I'm
going to add it just after my H next
which we can actually put there H next
free there we go and I'm going to catch
my image called 1. gpg I'm going to
remove this alt this useless alt and
there we go and now I get back to my app
I got my image that is displayed so this
is the first way of displaying an image
and of course after that I could have
had some CSS to change the size let's
try to display the second image also
there we go I got my second image that
is display there all right this is the
first way another way instead of always
using this pass what we could do is to
use an alas so I'm going to get back on
N.C config.js and remember I have
created this alas
previously this was the whole way to
resolve pass because now we can use root
deer and Source deer with next so I can
remove this one and and I could put for
instance assets okay and here I can type
slash and I can use root deer there we
go here Ro there and I can close it so
here there's a mistake I can close it
with Assets Now I did this what I can do
directly instead of having the wave that
I got here I can use at and at assets
will play the exact same role as the
wave and will retrieve for me directly
uh in the assets folder the image of
course if I have a folder I have to
follow the pass to this folder and when
I get back it's also working this is the
second way of using the pass and of
course it's very useful now let's talk
about the public directory we see that
here I got a folder assets and one gpg
file if I want to access this image what
I could do is assets. gpg but if I do
that of course I got a
44 because here n gs is not serving this
folder remember it says down there that
next doesn't autoc scan and doesn't take
in order this uh folder into his build
all right so basically because it's
processing actually basically if we want
to have a Public Image with no process
at all because assets is processing but
public here is not processing we can use
the public folder so here the public
directory is used as a public server for
static assets all right public server
for static assets so you're going to put
the image into the public folder and it
will stay as it is there will be no
compression there will be no processing
nothing else else no resizing it will
stay as it is the same for stylesheet
the same for any other file that you
will put in there you can get a file in
the public directory from your
application code or from a browser by
the root URL slash so let's try now I'm
going to create a new folder at the root
which will be public and I'm going to
move my two images there into the public
folder and I'm going to try to access it
back in my app I type the name of my
image as a URL and there we go I got my
image
available exactly like if I would take
it from a server and as you look at it
as you look at it it's directly
available into my URL but there is no
preprocessing of the image this image
will be available directly like this and
there will be no caching so if I want to
access this image basically what I can
do is to directly use the slash so here
instead of having all of this I can just
put the Slash and here the two so I'm
going to get back on on the app and
there we go slash will look directly
into the public folder which is very
useful if you want to fetch another file
like this you can use directly the
public folder but remember public means
that it's public so it's available on
the app all the time so you got to be
careful if you want to store files or
elements that you don't want to share
don't put it into the public folder put
it put them into the assets folder using
SVG as icons you might ask yourself how
to do it with assets and public folder
well actually the thing is that with SVG
you would have to use a plugin for it to
load them and there is is one called vit
SVG loader that helps you actually to
import the SVG from for instance the
public or assets folder and to render
them uh directly like a component so
here you got this uh uh package that is
available and the only thing that you
would need to do is to go on your vit
config.js and if you don't have it you
have to create it and then you uh give
the plug-in view or SVG loader all right
so so you can use a um a third part
plugin for next to load your SVG however
you know that I like to give you the
best tips to develop faster and
efficiently in vgs and if you want to
and especially next and if you want to
use SVG my advice would be to go on icon
dogs.org and the thing is that
everything is a component in vgs so
basically icons can be also component so
let me give you an example we are going
to catch an icon so here I'm going to
look at it and you will see that what we
can do can be very cool so here if I
type Bell and let's say that I'm looking
for a bell icon in SVG basically let's
say that I'm going to take this one you
see that on this website on e.g. org I
can download SVG as
components and here we see that I got
plenty other option I can also do it in
react I can download them directly what
I can do if I click here on component
view I can just come back go on my
component and here I'm going to create a
folder called icons and in icons I'm
going to create a bell. view and I'm
going to copy paste and directly I got
my SVG that is appearing here so let's
say that now I want to catch so I'm
going to remove this image I want to use
my SVG icon which is in my view file how
can I do it exactly like I explained to
you for the components um Liston I can
simply call icons Bell and here icons
Bell is going to call in the component
folder icons and Bell now it's done
let's get back to our application and
there we go we've got our SVG that
appears this way it's way faster than
using plugins that we can add to our
configuration this was my tips when you
want to use icons go on icon. org and
use them directly as
components you free introduce to us the
New Concept of composes if you already
coded react application or next GS
application you might know what are ooks
well basically it's it's exactly the
same as
composes however with the view
composition API introduced by viewfree
the idea is to split the code logic into
several files instead of having the same
logic everywhere mixed why we do that
because it makes the code lighter but
also because it help us to debug faster
and to have some code cleaner so we
created in view free the composes in
order to separate some code logic so
let's let's have an example because we
need something concrete here I got two
views I got index. View and I got
profile. View and let's say that in
index. view I would have a function
called say hello with just console log
hello there we go all right and I want
to trigger this function every time
index. view will be built so back in my
app I open and there we go I got hello
that is is console logged now let's say
that I want to have the same the same
function triggered in my profile. view
well it's a bit dumb because I got uh
the same piece of code written uh in two
different place and here the thing is
that it's two different function even if
they got the same name they got the same
name so it means that they are supposed
to do the same thing okay but they have
two declaration in two places say and
that could be a problem because one
could console log hello and the other
one could console log goodbye and that's
a problem here because we wish that say
hello could do the same thing to solve
that problem we could create a composes
that will contain our say hello function
so here I'm going to create a new folder
and this folder is going to be called
composes and now you understood next
free Auto Import is the main feature of
course next Free Will Auto import all
our composes so the convention says that
with view free we should name the
composes with a use before so let's say
that here we are going to call that use
utils Dots here what we're going to do
we are going to create a um const okay
called use U that we are going to export
and this would be a
function okay so let's get back at our
say hello let's say that in our function
we would have this say hello there and
now what we want to do we want to return
say hello now I got this file called use
utils that I could use everywhere in my
app because I have the autoimport
feature made by nfree so instead of
having this declaration there what I can
do is just destructure okay my use utils
and use utils come from where it comes
from this file composable so next free
understand that every file that is there
has a function and is going to record
this function and here the function that
we have is of course
USS so I got USS and what I need to uh
import is say hello and now I got my say
hello there that I can trigger of course
I can do exactly the same there and now
I don't get the problem that uh uh that
I have two different declarations so
here I can put hello from use utils back
and I update we see that I got hello
from use ues so I really encourage you
to work as much as possible with
composes and now you understood that we
can you don't need to import okay with
view free you would have do do this you
will have import from uh at composes etc
etc you can have the big benefit of the
Auto Import of the composable for the wi
next three and I really encourage you to
um gather all the business logic into
composes because it's easier to read
easier to debug and it doesn't um uh
make your code base heavier it's a very
good timing to talk about a very useful
library that a lot of view and N
developer are using this library is
called view use view use has been
created by anony fu is really known in
The View Community and there's a lot of
other developer that help him but
basically this vew use library is
working a bit like composes when you
install this Library you get tons of
method that helps you to develop faster
and that improve your developer
experience most of the time if you would
need to detect if you click outside you
would go into your composable and you
would click a function call const uh uh
on click outside okay that's really
basic a lot of developer are doing this
all the time well the thing is that if
you install V you don't need to do that
all you would need to do is to import
click outside coming from the vu's
library so as you see you got some
examples and it shows that you will um
save a lot of time if you use this kind
of Library instead of uh creating your
own function and at the same time think
about something the vew core team
actually worked on many function look at
this they F about everything so don't
think that you could do better than an
open source community that is working on
that all the time the the code quality
of this library is tremendous it's
amazing so do not waste your time
writing function and here you got a lot
of examples you may have a trouble and
this trouble could be certainly solved
by a function there so I really
encourage you to go on view use and to
install this library to use
it if you coded in next two you might be
uh familiar with the concept of plugins
let me give you an example let's say
that before you launch your application
you want to trigger some JavaScript well
actually it's not really before you
launch it but it's at a certain time
that you want to trigger some function
what you can do is to use
plugins Also let's say that you would
like to have a directive or some kind of
function available everywhere in your
app and you don't want to use a
composable to put this function and
import it you just you just would like
to click you would just like to have a
next app do something to trigger your
function where what you are looking for
are plugins on the official
documentation we can read that next
automatically needs the files in your
plug-in directory and loads them at the
creation of The View application so
basically what you need to do is to
create again and it's always the same
logic actually and this is why I love
next I can create my plugins folder and
inside I will create a my plugin. ts so
let's create this first plugin my
plugin. ts and there we go the main
difference is that those plugins can be
called at the initiation of your next
application so I got my plugin. ts if I
go down I see that I need to type export
default Define next plugin let's go
let's type export defa Define next
plug-in and here as an argument I can
type the next app because here at the
beginning I will have my context
available so let's console log this next
app that we already saw before and there
we go now I did this I can go back to my
app and try to trigger again and look at
that what I have is that before my
composable function that says hello from
USU I have my next app context available
however in next if we are using plugin
it's because most of the time we would
like to have some directive or to have
some function that we could trigger
everywhere like I said at the beginning
of this course in order to do that we
have an amazing example there really
simple to understand it's that we create
our plugin and we return an object and
inside this object we got a provide key
and this provide key will tell actually
to next hey record this as a function or
directive list because it's an object
that will be available in everywhere in
my app so let's create our own directive
and here is going to be exactly a bit
like this example I guess so I'm going
to get back there and what I'm going to
do I'm going to return an object object
and in this object I'm going to return
provide and provide here will wait for
something say hello okay say hello I got
say hello which actually will take a
message which would be a type string and
it will console log okay my uh my
message so I got Hello message there we
go now I've got this okay now I've got
this I can go to my index. view and I
can call
my hello function so how I can do it
well it's really easy to understand we
see down there that I can import hello
from n app and I'm going to import my
hello function which is here but
actually it's not hello it's say hello
so say hello actually will be available
and if you look at the object what I got
now is a dollar say hello so what we're
going to do first is to console log this
use next app which will return to me the
context and if I click and I look down I
got down there I got this say hello
function so now everywhere in my app I
got this say hello function that is
available what I can do now is to use
this function say hello simply by typing
dollar say hello and here I'm going to
put Gom for instance and when I get back
and I update there we go it's working
often plugins are used to inject into
the next uh context all the logic of a
certain Library let me give you an
example for Firebase if you would like
to have Firebase installed on your nuk
application you would use a plugin even
if there is a module for Firebase that
maybe we are going to see later as I
said to you here we got a very good
example on the next documentation we can
use plugins for first library and here
we got the uh module view gtag actually
to add Google analytics tags to your
next application a last example is to
change The View directive and here we've
got another example here we are going to
create a plugin and we see that we
inject again into our view app inside
the next app the directive focus and in
this directive Focus we are specifying
Behavior so this is something else that
you can do inside uh uh inside your
plug-in folder you could change your
directive directly there and say from
the start of the app hey I want to
change a behavior and this is what I
want to do so in plugins you can have
custom plugins that you create for
yourself and that create um some
triggers you have plugins that are
related to modules and you have plugins
that are related also to directive
actually you can create the plug-in you
want and that's the force of no
GS one of the main reason I moved from
view3 to n fre it's because of the
routing system but also because of
middle Wares because with nufree what we
can use is Middle Wares those file that
will trigger some operation before we
switch from root to another one so you
understood now that we can deal with
authentification with middleware and I
can say that with next three it's so
useful let's have a quick look on the
documentation next provide a
customizable root middleware frame
workk you can use throughout your
application ideal for extracting code
that you want to run before before
navigating to a particular
route that's amazing I I don't know if
you realize but that's amazing because
we can deal with several cases we want
to deal with thanks to
authentication there are three kinds of
root middleware Anonymous or inline root
middleware which are different find
directly in the page where they are used
so I get back to my app and I'm going to
create a folder called
middleware and I'm going to create a new
file and let's say that this file is
going to be called o. TS in this O.S I'm
going to export default a method called
Define next and here be safe because
what we want to have is Define root
middleware so
this method provided by next help us to
catch several parameter to and from are
from them so here I'm going to use two
from now what I'm going to do is to
conso log this two and this from all
right so now I got my
middleware and you probably understood
that there's a mistake because I want
this middleware to be triggered
everywhere
so if I get back to my app and I update
I don't get anything that is console log
and here on the line two and three of my
O.S I'm supposed to have defined a next
root middleware so on every root it's
supposed to execute all the code there
it's because here the global root
middleware is supposed to have a global
suffix so what I'm going to do is to
rename and put here.
global.
TS now I get back to the app I update
and there we go we see that now on this
root I have my two uh elements that are
triggered the first it's two this is the
root I'm going to and from this is the
root I'm going from so I'm going to put
slash and I think I already got a root
profile there and as you see and I got
data from where I come and where I go so
it's really useful to use this uh uh
Global actually middleware that can help
us to trigger some operation let's take
an example and let's say that we want to
check on every rout of our application
if we are logged in or not and we would
check that uh with a variable okay is
logged in okay which will be on false
all right well the thing is that later
we will have a store and in this store
we will have some kind of variable like
this so we will be able to check the
store first to see if we are logged in
or not and then we could take some
decision but there what we need to do is
to check with if we are logged in or not
otherwise if we would not be logged in
we would redirect we would redirect to a
login page and there what we want to do
we want to redirect
actually to the page we want to go and
this page we we have it because we have
two two is the destination two is the
destination so what I can do is console
log my two all right so when I get back
there I update and actually I'm going to
go exactly there okay I see that where I
want to go is to the uh full pass so
what I can do is to use a method that is
written there called navigate 2 navigate
to
and not from to do Full Pass if we are
loging we say okay you can go to the
destination you want to go otherwise if
you don't want to you have to navigate
to and the page here could be login so
this is a quick example on how we could
create an authentification system on
every route but what happen if I remove
This Global here we already saw that
when I remove this Global and I'm going
to remove this example I'm going to say
just console log hello from
middleware
o there we go we saw that nothing is
happening there so when I update nothing
is happening on my index page what you
can do also you can specify to your page
that you want to use this middleware art
so here in my page that I want to had a
middleware to I can type Define page
meta and this function that we already
saw to define the layout but we can also
use to many other uh things like title
etc etc we can say hey I want to use a
middleware and this middleware is going
to be off let's check that and when we
get back we see that hello from
middleware off if I go on profile I
don't get this hello from the
middleware and what I would need to to
do is to do exactly the same thing on
profile. view there is also a method
that you could use for instance inside a
plugin and this method is simply add
root middleware well basically what we
could do is to say to our plugin to add
a root middleware and we Define this by
the name of the plugin then by the
function and everything that you want to
trigger inside of it and you can specify
at the end if you want it to be Global
or not that's another way of adding a
middleware which is very convenient with
n3e it's that you can set up
authentication really fast depending on
your middleware that's an amazing
feature for
me with Nu 3 we can use what we call
modules and actually we had already this
in n 2 modules are like libraries you
have to install them and add them to
your next. config.js also modules are
made to simplify your integration and
simplify your developer experience these
next modules are actually running as
synchronous when your next application
is launched and these modules can be
created by anyone they can be published
on npm in order to help other developers
to save time to help you to develop
faster we've got Tailwind for instance
and if we click on Tailwind because we
already installed Tailwind on our next
GS application we see that on the
installation command we've got a prefix
called ATN gs/ tailn CSS it means that
this module this specific library is
made only for n gs and with the at n gs
we understand that we call actually the
Tailwind version for next GS but what is
the main difference with a current Li
Library well if we get back we see that
here we have a definition called a
supercharge so a module is here to
supercharge your next
project so we understand that this is a
plus that goes directly inside the real
life cycle of next so let's get down and
let's install for instance a package a
module called Next content so how do we
install next content where and how do we
install n module most of the time well
which is cool is that we have often a
documentation that comes with the
modules that have been created by the
developer and that is really useful
because when you click on it we arrive
on a new website on a new documentation
that explain to us how to use this
specific package there I'm going to
click on get started for n content and
we see that I don't get a new project I
want to add my new project so what I
would need to do is to add this uh uh
actually this module by stopping my
server and just typing y add d-d at next
SL content I'm going to type enter and
after the
installation I am able to see that in my
list I get next content as a Dev
dependency so it's not finished because
with next what we need to do when we
want to use modules that are uh entering
inside my next cycle actually my next
context I need to specify to my next
application to use this module so what
I'm going to do I'm going to get back
and go on N.C config dots and here I'm
going to type module which is an array
this array is waiting for different
modules and we see here that type 9
proposed me already axio as a package or
proxy but me I'm going to use next
content and when I get back I'm going to
type enter there there we go and now I
got next content so I'm going to type
yev and actually you will see that here
for this specific package nothing will
have changed however if I want to use
next content we see that I have to
create a Content folder so I'm going to
type content and inside I'm going to
create an index.md because next content
is a package to render markdown
files and now with next content next
understand that he has to look at
content so I'm going to type LOL and if
I want to render this content I have to
use a buil-in component called content
doc so I'm going to close this going to
get back
and now this buil-in component content
Doc is available because I installed
this module and I specify in next.
config dots to use it so I'm going to go
on my main page and inside instead of
having this hello I'm going to put
content Dock and when I get back I got
my content so as you see there are many
modules that you can use for instance
e8n which is actually for
internationalization and it's always wor
working the same what you need to do is
to install the corresponding package and
then to add it to your module array
inside your N.C
config.sys faster in your developer
experience when we create a frontend
application we often need a state
management system what is this exactly
well when you have a view and you
declare some variables inside this view
you have what we call a scope and this
variable are available only in that
scope however sometimes we need to have
some kind of State Management to just
share for instance the data or variables
between component pages and everywhere
in your application for that we use a
state management system and of course
with view free if you already coded a
view free application before you might
know viix or
P but with next fre we have a new
solution which is user State and we are
going to look at it right now next free
provide user State composes to create a
rea active and SSR friendly share State
across component SSR friendly what does
it mean later in this course we are
going to look at rendering mode and SSL
mean server side
rendering here next is talking about
user State and user state is a ref
replacement so if you don't know ref
it's a new function provided by viewfree
that actually we create for us a proxy
variable that will be reactive if you
want to know more I highly recommend you
to look at reactivity in view free let's
have an example here we have a basic
usage that I'm going just to copy paste
so I got my app there I'm going to
remove all of this and use the official
uh actually the official example so when
I get back there we go we see that when
I click I increase or decrease my
counter and my counter is up there and
is using a user State counter which is
returning actually a value all right
that's really interesting but what we
are looking for actually is to have some
kind of store or state inside our app so
here it is working all right but here we
see that we have shared State and this
might be what you are looking for go to
our composes and let's create a new file
called state.
s by the way in the previous course of
composes I told you that the convention
is to use as a prefix for your composes
it seems that here in this example it's
not respecting the convention here I see
export const there I'm going to copy
this all right and there we go now I got
this state. TS through composable that
is injected inside my whole application
and so I got two values available use
counter and use color and the thing is
that here we would like it work like a
state in VX why do I take VX as an
example because if you did next two
before you knew that a folder store
would be already uh written by default
and in this store every store that you
would create would follow the path of
viix so basically you would have viix
store that would be Auto imported Auto
injected inside your next content
application actually every store that
would be created inside this store
folder would be injected directly into
the next context of your application
here we've got an example of a viix
store and basically there's a state
there's mutation there's actions there's
dispatch all right but this is for viix
in the example provided by um next three
we see that this use State can work
exactly like a store and can return
actually just an object or a value that
could change so what we want to test we
want to test that is this counter will
be will have actually the same value
everywhere in my app so here instead of
having counter there I'm going to call
use counter which actually comes from my
state here I got my use counter and what
I want to do I want to create a
component and let's say that we're going
to have uh counter component counter.
View
that would have exactly the same code as
in my app now I've got this I can create
a new div and next to it I'm going to
call my counter so I will have a double
counter here what I can do is to put an
ID and let's put the ID Main and here
I'm going to put another ID which would
be counter when I get back to my app we
see that I got these two different files
I got this file which is the counter and
I got this one this this scope which is
main I want to be sure that my state
encounter will also change so let's
click and we see that actually my state
is changing in the two components here
we've got what we call a shared State we
can define global type safe States and
import them across the application so
the main question would be Gom why we
will use a state. TS that will be
actually a composable instead of using
viix or
P that's the question I asked myself
also and I found this very good article
on view mastery.com which is a reference
about view written by Michael T and this
article is called nufree State
Management paa versus US state and here
Michael is asking the same question as
me do I use n free home state management
solution user state or should I use n3e
with paa which is better well here is
the short answer provided by Michael
Ty p is what you get if you keep adding
more and more feature to user State more
complex app will benefit from the extra
features in Pia but user state is better
for small and simple apps this is the
short answer and I think everything is
said there if you have a big application
and once your user state is heavier you
should use a state manager like
P otherwise if you have a small
application you better use user State
and if you want to know more about why
we use user state in state of ref what
is State hydratation and what are all
the problem around it and why to use
uh either uh user state or ref I
recommend you to read this article
otherwise we will have to install p as a
state manager because yes even if I
showed you this state management system
by next free I also want to show you a
bit of Pina because yes for me I can't
make a course about nfree without
talking about P which is an amazing
State manager so let's have a look let's
install Pina and so I'm going to stop my
server and I'm going to type yarn at P
at P next so you understood now that
this Pia next is a module that I'm going
to add and if you want to look at it you
can go on the module page of next3 to
find it or otherwise you go on p.
vig.org and you look for nextjs so I'm
going to get back to my next. config.js
and I'm going to add P next there we go
now what I got is that I can use the
store outside of setup so I'm going to
type Yar Dev again and I'm going to
create a new folder at the root of my
application and this new folder will be
stores uh actually in this folder what
I'm going to put is actually yeah my
store they call it my store as an
example my store.js so now I need to
create my store so when I get back I got
an example there I got several examples
actually and what I'm going to do I'm
going to copy paste this use counter
store there we go so how does a store is
working as I said to you with P we got
State Getters and actions only all right
so now with the state we are returning
some value and we got Getters that are
actually uh like computed function that
will return to you the value when it's
updated and then we've got action only
the action are supposed to mutate our
store we've got another option we can
write our store with the viewfree way so
here as you see we've got ref we've got
computed we've got increment so when I
get back there I have the old way of
doing it now I'm going to copy paste and
we are going to look quickly at the
difference down there we have the view
free composition API that has been used
and up there we have the V2 which is
actually used with the option API state
are replaced by reference and gets are
replaced by computed properties I
decided to keep it on The View freeway
so with the composition API I got my
store I'm going to import my store which
is use counter store I'm going to create
a variable called store which we call
actually the counter store and I want to
console log it when I get back to my app
we see that I have the proxy that
represent actually my store and if you
are using view def tools which is
actually an extension for Chrome you can
see that there we've got access to our P
stores and we've got our counter just in
here we see that there are several ways
of dealing with the state management
inside next free you can have the user
State through composes or you can use
paa which is a more complete library or
module to to help you to deal with State
Management across pages and
components which is brand new with n3e
it's This Server directory that can help
us to create actually a backend and to
deliver some uh functionalities that are
related actually to API so on the
official documentation we can read that
next automatically scans files inside
the server Direct Dory API and server
routs and also server middleware
directories to register API and server
handlers with
HMR support so what we can see is that
we can use the Define event handler and
this Handler can directly return gson
data a promise or use event not. rest.
and to send a response all right let's
go directly into the subject and let's
create a server API uh folder so here
I'm going to create a new folder at the
root of my application and I'm going to
type server and inside because I I want
to follow the
documentation I'm going to create an API
folder so I'm going to click on there
and here I got an API folder so now if I
follow um what is written on the
documentation I understand that now I
can create an endpoint and which is is
cool is that when we look there we see
that later we will be able to fetch okay
we will be able to fetch a root SL API
SLO if we are creating a .ts file so to
start we are going to copy paste this
code and I'm going to create a simple
hello. TS file and there there we go so
my server is running and we see that in
my console
there is this Nitro build in 400
millisecond what is this Nitro we are
going to see that just after so I'm
going to get back there and I'm going to
open my application so my application
it's there and if I type slash API SLO
I'm supposed okay I'm supposed to have
an endpoint that respond to me actually
what we wrote before and when I type
this there we go so now we see that our
n application it's not only about front
end it's also about back end we have an
endpoint that is available and here that
is answering to us a Jon object so next
now has a role of a front end framework
but also of a backend framework actually
it was already the case before but now
we see that we can create our own end
points and to do some back end so let's
just console log this event object that
we've got there so I'm going to open
this I'm going to get back and I'm going
to type again on the uh end point and we
see here that we've got H3 event object
with a context Neal and a big node
object and we can see there that we've
got everything that we need uh uh to
handle this node call so and we got also
a res with a server response Etc Etc so
we can see that here we can catch events
going to this API folder and to this API
uh actually hello. TS uh endpoint on our
API okay but what is the point to have a
backend on my front-end application well
it can be for many reason that you would
need a backend for your application for
instance if you want to uh provide some
triggers or provide some action that you
would do not on the front end side but
on the back end side now next GS gives
you the opportunity exactly like NEX GS
because we can do the same with
nextjs it gives you the opportunity to
actually put some business Logic on the
backend side and not on the front end
side so how does it work well basically
on the server where you are going to
host your NS application it will also
run the back end and it will provide the
operation on the back end side and not
on the client side if you never did some
back end before I highly recommend you
to dive deep into no GS or at least a
little bit to understand how we create
backends it's not that you have to learn
everything about the back end to handle
this part of NS however if you want to
create some uh triggers and some end
points however it's always good to have
some knowledge to start creating
endpoints on a back end such as this one
if we continue to read the documentation
you see that we can make some call there
and we are using a method with a dollar
fetch however what is this dollar fetch
well we are going to see this in the
course data fetching but for now I'm
just going to copy this code there and
I'm going to get back to my application
so on the front end side and I'm going
to open my console and what I'm going to
do I'm going just to copy paste this
code so I'm going to get back there I'm
going to go on index and up there I
still have my content dock which is
there it's okay what I'm going to do I'm
going to type um await fetch uh API
hello so we have a top level await there
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
type cons response and I'm going to
console log my response and when I get
back there we go we see that my front
end called my back end
automatically and it called the API
folder with the endpoint I have created
in there see that in the same
application we can do full stack
operation because we can have a front
end and a back end so it can be very
useful if we continue we see that down
there we've got a server root option and
it is written file inside the server API
are automatically prefixed with API in
their root yes that's what happened here
when I type SL API SLO which is the name
of my file hello is of course the name
of the endpoint I got an API there uh in
my URL maybe I don't want it so for
adding server roots without API prefix
you can instead put them into server
Roots directory so let's get back and at
server here I'm going to create a new
folder called roots and in there I'm
going to copy paste my L.S that I got
there however I need to change the code
of this file so I'm going to get back
there and I'm going to type hello word
from Roots folder I'm going to save and
now I'm going to get back and instead of
having API hello up there what I'm going
to type is just slash hello and it will
work exactly the same however the
difference here is that I didn't return
a gson I just return a simple string if
I would like to to return a gon I could
do exactly the same as I did in the API
folder so back in my roots folder now
I'm going to just open these brackets
this way hello from Roots
folder and I'm going to save and I'm
going to get back I'm going to type
again and there we go I got my gson
there we just saw two ways of creating
server endpoint on njs we saw the API
folder
which will prefix all your endpoint
with/ API SL otherwise if you want to
create root without the API slash you
can put your endpoint inside uh The
Roots folder your file they look like
they export a default defin event and
law method and inside every time you can
provide operation you can trigger
actions whatever but every time you have
to return at the end the result result
of your endpoint you know me I try to
give you all the best practice all the
time when you are creating a file like
this it's creating actually an endpoint
and this endpoint will take the name of
your file well try to be concised every
time you are going to create some
endpoints the name of the endpoint
should be really logic and follow some
pattern here what we do we are creating
a hello root and this root
is supposed to have a method the method
can be post get patch delete whatever so
the best practice that I want to give
you now is to actually always put a a
suffix at your root here we have a root
hello and the method is supposed to be
get so I'm going to type get and now we
understood that um actually this root is
supposed to be a get method so if you
are going to try try to post to this
rout it's not going to work because the
suffix is now get when you put just
L.S it's like you are doing anything you
want so remember in NOS or if you don't
know in NOS when you are creating an app
you can specify the method by typing
app.get app. post app. patch and then
you provide an
action here what it does actually
without putting
suffix it does an app. all it means that
it's going to receive any request
depending on the method so the best way
is always to specify of course if you
get a post instead of get you're going
to P put a post if you got a delete
you're going to put a delete etc
etc previously on the server part we
talked about Nitro because when we
launch our application on next 3 if we
look at the terminal we can read that
next is running on nro what is Nitro
well actually nro it's a server engine
and actually on the official
documentation we've got some information
about Nitro next threee is powered by a
new server engine
Nitro it is crossplatform support for
not GS browser service worker and more
because before n was running on NOS now
it took Nitro this new engine that help
us to make n free running serverless
support out of the box API root support
that we saw already on the server part
automatic Cod splitting as sync loaded
shunks hybrid mode for static plus
seress site and we will see that this
hybrid mode is the brand new feature of
n 3 development server with OD module
reloading there's also a website for
Nitro on
n.s. and if we click on get started
suddenly we see that on the
documentation we recognize what we've
got on our server part on next free we
see that we have this method called
Define event and learn and we see that
we can create actually a backend a
server with need
nro so why N3 decided to use Nitro for
many reasons and one of this reason it's
that we can use the cache API to Cache
elements okay so the thing is that NS is
really known for uh its SEO performance
and its server side rendering mode we
are going to see later the modes however
now let's talk a little bit at how we
can cash element with n3e basically
what's going to happen when we use SSR
is that every time we are requesting a
server the server is going to build the
application and deliver it to the client
the difference with the spa mode is that
on the spa mode everything is done on
the client side with the SSR mode and
the ibrd mode that we are going to see
later we can cache elements which means
that instead of every time there is a
request a n application has to be build
we cach the element every five minutes
for instance and every five minutes
somebody's going to come it's going to
build a cash version and during these 5
minutes it's going to deliver the
content to the uh next call also Nitro
provide to us a built-in storage layer
that can abstract our file system or
database to any data source and that can
be very useful especially if you are
doing some
redit we you can store actually some
elements when we need them then of
course it is backend so we can use the
router and Link from nro that help us to
create some roots and some end points to
provide some
operation and which is really funny and
at this point of the course you already
saw a lot of Auto Imports with nxg
we have also Auto Import with Nitro what
I like especially about nro also is that
there is a deployment uh documentation
that helps you to deploy for instance on
netlify that helps you to deploy nro if
you want to use it also separately from
nuggs so it was necessary for me to talk
about Nitro to have a quick presentation
of it because this course is not about
Nitro it's about next but if you want to
do something some back end on the next
side you might want to focus on nro and
especially to go for instance on the
official repository which is on NGS
organization NGS it's actually basically
what uh the organization that created uh
Nitro but not also Nitro some other
methods that are used inside next
GS3
this is probably the most important
lesson of this whole course about next
and this is probably the one you were
waiting for because no GS is really
known for its options about
rendering so previously in the lessons I
was talking about how you can render
differently your
applications and it's not related to NS
however NS is providing many options
that are very useful when you want to
take care about the SEO of your
application for instance so for this
lesson we are going to look at two
documentation the old one the one about
next 2 and then we are going to switch
to the next three to see the
difference what is rendering well we can
look at a good definition about
rendering on the new
documentation and we can see that here
it's written both the browser and server
can interpret JavaScript code to render
vgs component into HTML
element so we can see that we can render
our application from vgs component into
HTML element on the client side and on
the server side this step is called
rendering next supports both client side
and Universal rendering the two
approaches have pros and cons that we
will cover in this section but before
let's get back to the old documentation
and let's look at how it was written
before we talk directly about s side
rendered seats or Ser side rendering SSR
and static site Ser side render SES are
rendered on the server each time the
user request a page therefore a server
is needed to be able to serve the page
on each
request static site which is the
opposite of SSR are very similar to S
side rendered application with the main
difference being that static side that
render that build time therefore no
server is
needed the static sites they are not
build every time there's a request they
are build are build time when you type
npm build for instance so it makes a big
difference because on stic side it's
difficult to fetch the data and build
your HTML document to deliver it to the
uh browser because when you are fetching
the static website it is already built
so the data is static there so for SEO
reasons what you want to have is that
when the robot is arriving on your
website you may want to have all the
data the fresh data already Fetch and
completed interpolated everywhere for
that you will use SSR and with next two
we had the option SSR true which we
could put on next. config.js or TS so
when I go on N.C config
dots if I want to put the SSR mode the
only thing that I have to type is SSR
then true and from there my application
now will will be built on the server
side and it doesn't change something
immediately on your application but this
new rendering mode actually change a lot
of things in your data life cycle if we
look at the new documentation again we
have some explanation client side only
rendering out of the box a traditional
vgs application is rendered in the
browser and the client so the computer
actually not the server or the phone
then vgs generate HTML elements after
the browser download and passes all the
JavaScript code and this schema is
explaining it very well the browser
download an empty HTML document then the
browser download and run the
JavaScript and thep is rendered and
interactive this is the client side
rendering we see that the G JavaScript
is not executed we got pros and cons
about this technique the development
speed is a pro when working entirely on
the client side we don't have to worry
about the server compatibility of the
code for example the using browser only
API like the window object because yes
on the server side rendering you don't
get any window object so that's a
problem but however it's a development
speed feature that is a pro of the
client side rendering it's cheaper
running a server at the cost of
infrastructure and we've got also other
problems related to this and offline
because code entirely runs in the
browser it can nicely keep working while
the internet is unavailable which means
that with the client side only when you
fetch the application you don't need
anymore to have actually internet
running in instead if you are uh you are
fetching some data but it can work
offline which is
amazing the cons of the client sign
rendering is the performance the the
user has to wait for the browser to
download pass and run the JavaScript
file the server side rendering is faster
and the client side needs actually a
good internet connection and it needs
also memory to make the work to render
the application in the browser with the
server side rendering it's faster and
finally that's the main topic with the
client side rendering we have very bad
SEO
performances and that is maybe why you
are watching this video this is because
you would like to have good SEO
performance on your next
application and with the client side
rendering this is very bad to do SEO
actually it's useless to try to do SEO
because your page is not render at the
right time and as written here we can
see that as search engine crawlers so
the robot of Google for instance won't
wait for the interface to be fully
rendered on their first try to index the
page so if you have a SEO problematic on
your project you should do server side
rendering then you got what we call
Universal rendering client side plus
server side well it's actually the
server side rendering what happens is
that when the browser request a URL with
universal rendering enabled the server
returns a fully rendered HTML page on
the browser so as I say to you it's
going to make the work for you and just
send you the
page whether the page has been generated
in advance or cached and is rendered on
the fly at some point next has run the
JavaScript code in a server
environment making a static page
interactive in the browser is called
hydration that's what we saw before
that's a good definition of
hydration so basically this Universal
rendering is working this way the fully
HTML is sent to the browser and rendered
so the work here has been done about all
the data completed on the server side
then the browser download and run the
JavaScript in
background then a new step is coming on
our cycle because at that time we need
to get this hydration step complete and
hydration again it's making a static
page interactive in the browser so when
you use SSR you might have some errors
related to
hydration it's maybe because you didn't
make the static page interactive in the
browser it didn't took time to complete
actually the interactivity of your page
it's a very common error that you get
when you are doing some SSR what are the
pros and cons of SS
of course it's the opposite of the
client side we got a search enzy
optimization Pro which is very big
Universal rendering delivers the entire
HTML content to the page to the browser
as a classic server application
webcrawlers can directly index the page
content because at this step we have the
irration and then we got also the the
page content already rendered which
makes Universal rendering a great choice
for any content that you want to index
quickly then of of course you get the
performance user can get immediate
access to the page content because
browser can display static content much
faster than JavaScript generated
one however with SSR and Universal mode
we've got some cones and the first for
me it's the developer constraint that is
written there server and browser andv
vironment don't provide the same apis
and it can be tricky to write code that
can run on both side
seamlessly of course
writing HTML CSS vgs react whatever on
client side is a different Behavior than
writing it on the server side when you
choose to work on the server side you
will encounter maybe errors that you
never encountered before and you will
have to deal with it however the next
documentation is very well provided to
deal with those problems also it's a
problem of cost a server needs to be
running in order to render pages on the
Fly this add a monthly cost like any
traditional server of course because you
are not just delivering some pages you
are making your server running to make
the work instead of the client's browser
so it has a cost of course however the
server calls are highly reduced thanks
to the universal rendering with a
browser taking over on client side
navigation why do we use uh Universal
rendering where for blogs marketing
website portfolio e-commerce website and
Marketplace finally by default n uses
SSR or Universal rendering to provide
better user experience and performance
to optimize search engine
indexing what is new with n
free and what was not in n 2 which means
here it's the ibrid rendering ibrid
rendering allows different caching rules
per root using root rules and decide how
the server should respond to a new
request on a given URL so now basically
with this hbd thing what we can do is
that we can specify on each page what
strategy we want to choose either client
side either uh Universal rendering or
Ser side rendering but also what we can
deal with is caching and as I explained
before
what we can do is to choose uh when we
want to cach our page and to put an
interval between the time we want to
have fresh data caching help us to deal
with this server that will build
actually every time there is a request
your application and deliver it instead
of uh dealing with every request and
every time building the app what we can
do is to cach our
application and of course this ibrid
rendering is possible because of nitro
the new server engine that powers next
free so please refer to nro to know more
about caching and we can continue on the
root rules because previously every root
page of next and server must use the
same rendering mode client side and
Universal now when IBD we can specify on
the root what we want to use using root
rules you can Define rules for a group
of next root change rendering mode and
assign a catch strategy based on root so
down there we've got an example with
Define next config so you understood
that it happens there in our next.
config dots so what I can do instead of
having this SSR true is to have a root
rule entry and in this root rule entry
which is an object I can specify the
name of the root the URL of the root
which is related there on a page and I
can specify if I want to use server side
rendering or not if I want to use some
header for instance or if I want to have
just static and I can also work on
headers with redirect and status code
and etc etc so with this root rules we
can specify with this options okay we
can specify which type of rendering we
want to use and that's the new thing
with n3e this ibrid possibility that we
didn't get before we had to put on the
entire application that we want to use
SSR or just static now we can use
both when we go on the official
documentation we can see that next
provide use fetch use lazy fetch use
Asing data and use lazy assing data so
we are going to start by use Fetch and
what we're going to do at first is to go
on our project and on next.
config.rb site all right so now I'm back
and now my application is not uh
declared as a server side rendering mode
for now so by default next free is on
SSR but we just remove this SSR mode so
everything is happening client side for
now and we are going to start with use
fetch within your page components and
plugin can use use fetch to universally
fetch from any URL universally it means
on the server side or on the client side
this composable provides a convenient
wrapper around user syn data and fetch
so that's very nice to see however what
is a syn data we going to see it after
and what is fetch well it's actually
dollar fetch because we know that with
NOS we have this method fetch that help
us to fetch some data and actually it's
also available in JavaScript regularly
so we have this dollar Fetch and if we
go on the API side
documentation of next we can see that
the definition of use fetch is these
composes provide a convenient wrapper
exactly what we read Around assing data
and fetch dollar fetch so it's a
combination between use assing data and
fetch and if I click on dollar fetch we
see that dollar fetch is actually a a a
function that is globally
exposed and that function comes from a a
library called offet and when I click on
ofet I arrive on a
repository and it's called a better
fetch API works on node browsers and
workers so this fetch here is available
on three sides note browser and workers
and it comes from of course NGS the
unified JavaScript tools that we talked
about before so use fetch automatically
generate a key based on URL and fetch
options provide type ins for request URL
based on server roots and infer API
response type and down there we've got
an example so we see that at first our
use fetch method can be destructured and
it can be destructured in different uh
types and we can look at this type down
there we've got data which maybe will be
the response and of course it will be
the response but we got also pending and
pending can be a loading state that will
be very useful we got also refresh which
means that actually later we will get a
function called refresh that when we
click on it will refresh the call and
the data we've got execute and we got
also error to uh actually display the
error and as options in our fetch we've
got a lot of other elements but we are
going to come back at it just after what
I need to do for myself is just to fetch
from an API and actually which is cool
with next is that we can create a server
site so what we got here is a server
folder and inside I got a product a
product wot which is available at local
API product and I got this gon and you
understood now that this root products
will distribute my gon array so back in
my products. ts what I can do is just to
import my data and when I call this end
point it will return to me the data from
my gson so I'm going to get back I'm
going to update and there what I'm going
to do I'm I'm going to go on locost API
products and there we go we've got our
data there so the thing is that now on
my index what I want to do is to just
fetch this endpoints so what I'm going
to do is simply to put const data and
like it would be a response actually I'm
destructuring here my response I'm going
to type use Fetch and here it's going to
be API SL products and and what I want
to do I want to console log this data
there we go let's get back let's update
and we see
suddenly that we have actually a
reference and which is cool is that
immediately the data that is coming from
my API has been turned into a reference
value so what we need to do is to type
data. value because there is some value
there and there we go we see that we've
got our data with our array however it's
still a proxy so that's a bit a problem
what I would need to do is first I'm not
going to call it data however I'm going
to call it products and what I would
need to do is actually to transform to
row if I want to access into my
JavaScript to the data this products dot
uh value there we go I update and
suddenly there we we go I got my 10
products available which is amazing that
was for the JavaScript part however if I
want to put it into my um template I
would put product there and what's going
to happen there amazing what's happening
is that we've got our uh products
display there and here the most
interesting part of use fetch it's that
right now I got this data there so I can
put as an option here I can put as an
option a method called transform with
transform I can say that I want to
change the the the the model that is
returned to my view I'm going to do is
to open an object just after my call
here and of course later you may need to
put some kind of headers or anything
else you can do it there all the keys
that you need to find are in the API
docs and here we see that we got many
keys such as key method query params
Eder lazy immediate watch anyway and
what we want is to use transform and
with transform what I'm going to do is
to access to my products and here what I
want to return is actually products dot
data because I got this data which give
me the array and what I want to have
immediately is just the array and not
this data in front of it so you see you
can use transform to get it now if I go
to my next.
[Music]
config.sys Ser side rendering it will
work also and you won't see the
difference at all and what we want to do
now we want to use this loading uh
pending actually uh that is available
there which is a Boolean so if I get
back to the use f documentation we see
that I got this pending which is a
Boolean and what I would like to do is
to display actually a loader while I'm
waiting for an asynchronous call so
what we would like to use is another
function which is called use lazy fetch
because use fetch is freezing your
application until the moment it received
the data and then it renders the data
with use La fetch we want to display a
loader so display the the the
application immediately and display a
loader instead so it means that here in
my data what I need to do is actually to
return a promise so here it's going to
be an asynchronous call and what I want
to do is to return a new promise the old
way okay and then here I would have a
resolve and reject I'm just going to use
resolve I will not reject and there I'm
going to actually put a set timeout
function and this set timeout function
will answer after 2,00 2000
millisecond and what's going to happen
is that I'm going to resolve and what
I'm going to resolve is my data okay so
I'm going to save this and back in my
application what I'm going to do I'm
going to say hey if it is pending I want
to have loading otherwise I want to have
the products all right so we have a
function which is called use lazy fetch
which is a use fetch but that is not
freezing our application and on uh the
um products um Endo we have a promise so
we're going to wait for some time
actually 2,000 milliseconds or 2 seconds
to render our app so let's try I'm going
to update and what's happening is that
we have a loading during 2,000
milliseconds and we have then the uh
array that is displayed which is very
cool because most of the time with this
useless fetch
we would like to have some kind of
skeleton waiting for the app and it's
working very
well let's talk now about use Asing data
within our
page components and plugins can use use
Asing data to get access to data that
resolve asynchronously and we have a
definition about the difference between
use Fetch and useing data use fetch re
receiv the URL and gets that data
whereas us sync data might have more
complex logic use fetch URL is
equivalent to user sync URL fetch URL
it's developer experience sugar for most
common use case and down there we've got
an example of actually this user syn
data which actually is fetching an
endpoint with a counter uh there example
and this user sync with this time a key
and another URL and a function which
calls actually dollar Fetch and it
returns a promise and it's using the
call back that you will put in it so
there we've got this fetch which is
there and we've got this user Sy data so
the best thing is to put an example in
my endpoint I'm going to create a new
function which actually will wait for a
promise
on a product count so we've got a
product count value up there and after 2
milliseconds or 2 seconds we are going
to actually increment this product count
and finally we are going to return this
product count so when we are going to
call this/ Api SL product we will wait
for 2,000 milliseconds so we will need
on the uh index. view to wait for that
call so it would be asynchronous and
finally we will return our product count
so back in my index. view what I will
need to do is to use assing data on a
key which could be product and there
what we will need to do is to open this
function and this is our call back we
will have the answer of this Fetch and
this is this fetch that is going to make
the call and remember this promise will
be returned and then we will get the
data and we will have our pending there
so I'm going to get back I'm going to
update and what we see is that there we
go we've got our product count but there
was no pending now I know that my server
is running and that there is this uh
actually every time I fetch this
incremental uh function what I can do is
here using a function to refresh my call
so what I'm going to do actually is to
declare in my template a button and this
button will trigger a function that will
be called refresh and this refresh
function will use another function
provided by no which is refresh next
data and here this is where I'm going to
use the key of my function so I got
products which is there so I get back
and when I click we see that I got
finally my loading because it's already
uh rendered and every time I refresh
it's incrementing my product count okay
so now I'm going to use actually use
lazy Asing data and it's the same uh
thing as um use um use lazy fetch sorry
if instead of having an incremental
function we would have a set interval
that would be actually um triggered
every second now what I what I have is
this use lazy as sync however I don't
have any asynchronous uh actions there
so what I can be back is on user sync
data and when I get back and I click on
refresh we see that it's been 33
actually I said product count but it's
actually seconds I got 36 seconds 42
seconds that my server has been running
because it's already turning there and
we've got this product count incremental
every second we saw that next3 is is
providing to us several method to fetch
data the first method is use Fetch and
actually use fetch which is a composable
help us to fetch data universally so on
front side and on the backand side and
we can fetch that from any URL and
actually use fetch is a combination
between asynchronous C which is can be
used with the composable usering data
and dollar fetch which is coming from
the method of fetch from the library and
the organization of nggs we also saw
that we got many other options that we
can pass on our fetching composes
provided by next and this function can
help us to watch some elements to
refresh or to put some adders some keys
method queries and params also nree is
working with cash and we've got a
function called clear n data that help
us to clear the cash data that we fetch
because when we use with assing data the
key we get some cache that can implies
some data that will be not fresh to
refresh the data you can use the clear n
data function the common problem is to
pass the client headers to your API and
there is a method uh provided by n which
is use request header and we see here
that we can pass directly the headers on
use
fetch
if you have a front endend application
you might want to work on the SEO the
search engine optimization is going to
help you to be found on Google and of
course with nfree we got everything we
need to index every page with the right
SEO metas that we can put inside a
built-in composable that is available
which is use head on the official
documentation we see that we got several
option to uh set the s SEO metas of our
app and the first one is to go on our
N.C
config.txt
allows you to customize the Ed for your
entire app this method does not allow
you to provide reactive data if you need
Global reactive data you can use useed
in app. view so if we go here on the N.C
config GS the first thing that we can do
is to open an app dot um an app object
actually and inside we can put a head
okay so here this head is going to be
everywhere in every page of your app so
if you have several page later there it
will take the head from here and put it
everywhere so let's get an example so
I'm going to put title next course on
YouTube whatever I'm going to save this
look at my server so it's running again
and then I came I come back and what we
see up there is that I got next course
on YouTube that is inserted here if I
inspect and I open my ad we can see that
suddenly I got my title so let's
continue let's say that there I'm going
to have some kind of description um this
is a repository for um a course about n
free for YouTube so here we see that
description is not available of course
because you got to stick to the model of
the add object so when I go on here what
I can see is that on app I can specify
many things and I can specify add later
we will see the whole configuration but
for now let's just stick to uh this SEO
thing so I got my Ed and we see that
actually what I'm trying to put is a
meta so this description is supposed to
be a meta and what I can do is to open
this Meta Meta is actually an array and
inside we're going to put some objects
and these objects here will got name
content a lot of stuff so the mea that I
want to put actually it's actually
content and here this is where my
description should be so I'm going to
put name and then I'm going to put
description there we go he
understood so I'm going to save now I'm
going to get back I'm going to update
and I'm going to open my Ed and I will
see if I will get my description okay I
got my description which is available
there so when we look at actually the
documentation we can see that we can add
also link style script no script and
finally we will find something like this
and we will get all the SEO provided by
default on the N.C
config.txt
however if you don't get this let's
remove it and let's doing it Page by
page so I'm going to get back to the
first page which is index there and I'm
going to get back also to 2D
documentation there so when I get down
and here I had an example that I could
use again we already so that we can put
everything on head I can also use Page
by Page this use head uh composable the
use head composable function allows you
to manage your head tags in a
programmatic and reactive way powered by
you view use head view use again we saw
it before it's a combination actually of
many composes that we can use use in a
library in the library views so what I
want to do I'm going to do exactly the
same and if we look at this object
inside use head we can see that it looks
exactly the same as in N.C config dots
so I'm going to get up there I'm going
to open a script as setup and the thing
you should not miss there is that you
want to say that you are going to use TS
okay as a lang so I'm going to use
typescript so let's use this composable
I'm going to type use add and inside
there I'm going to put everything that I
need so just going to copy paste
actually this example so here I'm going
to have a title and I'm going to put
this is my um uh
homepage for next course and I'm going
to put as a description uh page where
you are going to find everything about
this course course of next or okay then
I could put some body attributes then I
could put some scripts or links or
whatever all right this is done I have
complete my metas on my use ad and every
time I'm going to go to index I'm going
to find in the Ed actually all the
content that I have added so this course
is not really about SEO but it's just a
good way here that I'm showing you to
had some SEO on a specific page we would
catch this ID with the use root composes
um available by view free and we would
catch actually the param of this product
ID and then we would inject this product
ID directly inside our Tile For example
right now I'm on the index. viw page if
I go on the profile. viw page actually I
want I would like to change the uh so
again I'm going to open a script setup
lengths and I'm going to do exactly the
same I'm just going to use add there
there and I'm going to write my SEO and
there I'm going to write my SEO
concerning my page so here I'm going to
have a title which will be profile page
okay now here I'm on index and if I go
on slash profile we see that my uh SE uh
metas have changed of course so you
could work on every page you would like
to put SEO on and of course if you would
not have some SEO you could provide it
uh here inside the use head object and
another thing is that I don't know if
you noticed but in the previous example
we had this script so you could add as a
script there direct links with the use
head thanks to the use head the script
you would like to uh launch so right now
we've got a console log hello world so
when I come back to uh this index page
we see that I got my my Hello world that
has been triggered here this is a good
way when you want to call a CDN on a
specific page instead of putting the CDN
link here in N.C config dots there is
another way to deal with SEO it's by
components n provides title Bas no
script style meta links body all those
buil-in components that we can interact
directly with your metadata within your
component template so let's have a look
there we see that we got
just a specific template there and we've
got a head component with title just
down there so I'm going to get back in
my index and I'm going to remove all of
this and what I'm going to do is inside
my uh homepage I'm going to use this
head that I got there and I'm going to
use the title buil-in component so this
is my title for any reason you would
like to have this component there so
when I get back and just I update there
we go we see that I have this is my
title and if we continue we can see that
I can add some description and some
style also so in my case it's useless
because I already got Tailwind but I
could have a dynamic title so I'm going
to add my Dynamic title and here this is
my Dynamic title of course if it would
be a dynamic title it would be under a
ref so I'm going to get back and look at
that I got this is my Dynamic title and
we saw that the background was suddenly
green however this body green here has
been removed by my Tailwind so we could
had some style we could have some many
other elements related to the built-in
components provided by next as I said to
you before you could have some Dynamic
data and here we've got an example with
the reactivity reactivity is is
supported on whole properties as
computed computed gets ref and reactive
there we've got the example we could
inject the title that we got there
inside our user head of course if you
want to use third party scripts you can
also inject the scripts as we saw in the
user head before and you can say with
the body true that you want them to
appear at the end of your body and not
specifically into the template remember
when we talked about the layout we saw
that by we could put the layout we would
like and we use Define page meta the
buil-in
composable which is available everywhere
in my next application and here we see
that we can also Define the SEO through
the Define page meta so what is the
difference between use head and Define
page meta well the documentation doesn't
explain very well what's the difference
between defined page meta and use head
but I guess that if you really want to
work on SEO you would use use head and
Define page meta would be for more less
specific data that you would put into
your
metas the life cycle hooks what is it n
provides a powerful hooking system to
expand almost every aspect using hooks
this feature is powered by NGS hook
these hooks are available for n module
and build context right here we got the
example with close
however if you want to have the list of
all the hooks you can go there in the
API documentation at Advanced and then
you can click here on life cycle Hooks
and suddenly we've got the list of every
hook that we can use with a description
and it's also telling us the environment
we can use because sometimes it can be
server sometimes it can be client etc
etc the other way is to go here inside
your N.C
config.sys hook and suddenly we can look
at the interface of the next hook and
down there we've got a list actually
which is exactly the same and we see
that we've got Bild before Pages extend
Imports etc etc we've got a lot of hooks
when we can trigger some operations so
I'm going to pick up uh a status ready
because it's in the list and instead of
having this uh next that I'm going to
catch I'm going to just console log the
context because I guess that I got my
context already available there I'm
going to stop and restart and I'm
supposed to have my context that is
console log and we can see it there so
sometimes you would like to create some
hooks at certain moments and you would
like to trigger some operation for any
reason well you can use actually all
those hooks that are available there
and be safe because some hooks they are
triggered in some environment some can
be server and client some can be only
server some can be only clients another
thing that we could do is to use those
life cycles inside a plugin so here
we've got an example of a plugin that
would be triggered every time there is a
page start so I'm going to copy paste
this I'm just going to remove this hook
that I have there and I'm going to go on
my plugin and I got a plugin. TS that
comes back from a previous core and here
to my context I would add a new hook on
app created and I would like to console
log from plugin and what we see that I
already got hello from plugin and here I
got hello from plugin to I could add
some ooks from some plugins when I would
like to trigger some operation at
certain step of the initialization of my
another subject that we are not going to
treat here because it's related to n but
not directly is the usage of next kit
next kit is the library that helps you
to create modules and if you would like
to create a module also you could Loop
through the next context and add your
own hook inside the module that you
would like to
create in terms of configuration next
give us access to a config file at the
root of our application in this config
file we can configure the whole project
but we can also actually add some
modules we can add some CSS pass or we
can add some specific configuration
related to the module we add previously
we looked at the N.C
config.sys we've got Tailwind CSS so
basically with the module of Tailwind
that I didn't use actually what I could
do is instead of having this Tailwind
doc config.js I could grab actually this
whole object there and add it here in
tawin CSS directly here that's the
purpose of this N.C
config.sys file from another Library
well the idea is to never have this
config file except the n.
config.sys a method provided by next
natively we can inject this big object
and in this big object there will be the
all configuration okay so when we look
at it we have a lot of options and which
is interesting is that we can access
this config also this runtime config we
can access it inside our dome by just
using this inside our view then later
we've got a lot of configuration and
again this app config is um available
and yeah if we want to look uh deeper at
it you can go on get started
configuration but for me now what I want
to do is to show you most of the options
that are available actually in this
configuration file during this
presentation we are not going to pass on
every uh configuration key that you can
had it will be useless I'm just going to
talk about those that are the most
useful in my opinion previously we
already worked on some Alas and
especially on the assets folder so
instead of having a very long pass that
you will write by yourself with points
and slash you can use those aliases and
here you got the options that says that
actually you can access through the uh
specific folder that you want with the
related pass so instead of having slash
and root de we would add a at or for
instance or we would add asset slame of
the image.png so that's a very useful
config that you can have then we have
the app object you have the base URL if
you want to change the base URL of your
application you have the build assets
there so basically when you build your
application you have uh by default this
underscore next okay the folder name for
the build seat assets relative to Bas
URL you can change it with build assets
there you got the CDN URL an absolute
URL to serve the public folder from
production only so basically here if you
would like to change you would type
directly CDN URL blah blah blah
immediately okay you got the head that
we already saw in the course on SEO that
helps you to define the SEO for the
global application which can be actually
here a problem because sometimes you
want to have different SEO data or metas
inside every page keep alive that can be
disabled keep alive again it's when you
want to keep alive a component with its
data instead of uh just destroying it
inside your app you got the layout
transition we didn't see the transition
however you imagine that irritating from
view with no you can do some transition
you can turn on on false or through your
uh layout transition same for the pay
transition you you can change the root
ID and here we see that on my div I got
underscore unor n if I want to change
this ID I can do it with the root ID so
basically I would go there and say that
for now the root ID would be Gom in in
for instance there's also the build
option that helps you to change actually
the name of the build directory that you
will have so here we got next there and
this is the build of your application
it's actually what is delivering your
application there if you want to change
the name you can type Builder and it
will create a folder with a new name
instead of
next you got the debug option which is
clearly cool because it logs out when
you get a problem or not um it prints
out o names timing on the server logs
everything that is related to the next
app if you want to turn it off you can
go on your app and just type here debug
uh false and then you will not have the
console log in your console then you got
the dev server option if you want to
improve your um developer experience and
change for instance the host the HTTP um
the port the URL you can do that in the
dev server object inside you just enter
those key and you change them if you
want to customize all the architecture
of your project and change the name of
the folder for any reason you can use
also deer and inside deer you can
specify where you want assets to be so
change the name of assets the name of
layout middleware Pages plug-in public
and static it can happen to you that you
have extension that are not resolved by
next and you have to specify them inside
your N.C
config.txt denion array and we've got
some. ggs file. gs6 MGS dots. TS x.v or
or maybe we could have some gql if you
do some graphql you would have to
declare them inside your N.C config dots
so especially there what I would do is
here for instance to say extensions
which will be an array and it says CSS
but actually it's not CSS it would be
like graphql or it would be gql for
instance and then my next application
would resolve these uh files with this
exchange previously we already saw the
modules so you can had a module entrance
and had your modules there you can also
use the root deer option that helps you
to Define where is your next application
and where next has to look at when it's
building your app if you want to work on
the configuration of vit you can also
doing it in N.C
config.ru configuration the public
directory the resolve the rout the
server or the option related to view and
finally there is a big set of option to
configure webpack because if you are
already a front-end developer you know
that with webpack you will have some
configuration that you would do through
a webpack doc
config.txt
one of the most interesting modules
provided by the N Community is n content
why let me give you an example sometimes
you are creating websites and on those
websites there's only static content
this static content is just written
directly in RW on your
HTML well and you don't need necessarily
to create some JavaScript interaction
and stuff you just want to put some
static content such as text videos or
images whatever for that what you would
do is just to create an app and write in
HTML your title your paragraph and stuff
however one of the most interesting
thing is that you could write this
content in
markdown and writing it in markdown
would be easier than writing a whole
application in HTML CSS and to set it up
etc etc next content is providing an
amazing solution for that kind of
problem most of the website that are
written to be documentations are static
content let's take an example here we've
got this Nu content website on content.
nos.org
and this website is just static content
there's only text return down there so
what we would like to do is not to write
HTM ml but instead to write markdown and
maybe sometimes we would like just to
write Jon to display some website we can
do that with no content with the module
no content we just need to add a folder
called content and no is going to watch
our folder and translate our markdown
files into HTML Pages it will even do
the rooting between the pages and you
will be able to change from a page to
another one just by creating the file
you will not need to register any route
you will not need to do anything it will
work really easy so what I propose to
you is to create a Content uh actually a
Content website a study website with
next content so I'm going to click on
get started and down there here I got a
command npx nuie init content app so I'm
going to copy paste this get back and
I'm going to enter in my folder there we
go
and here it's going to create for me a
Content application it's a next
application so everything that you've
learned inside this course will be
available inside this app so I'm going
to enter in into it once I'm into my
project what I can see again is that
it's a very very light project there's
only an app. view with a next page at
the root I got a page component with a
slug and I got this content dock content
doc is just the the rooting system of n
content uh a built-in component provided
by n content that display all the pages
that will be in content and if I look in
my package.json what I can see is that
as Dev dependencies I got next I got
next content and I got this folder
called content and inside I have mark
down files I have about I got index and
just let's run our project
and that's it we have our website
running next content and it says this
page correspond to the SL root of your
website blah blah blah and these two
pages are rendered by the pages slug do
viw so here we see that we've got a slug
and we've got our index so I'm going to
try to go on slab to see and there we go
I got this about page and actually this
about page is coming from here so here I
can write in markdown so to write in
markdown the syntax is really simple you
can find a lot of website that will
teaches you how to write in markdown you
may know already markdown because you
already wrote some read me by the past
but here I can write content okay so I'm
going to save this and as you see
immediately it's rendered so why would
we do that instead of creating HTML
Pages well the thing is that um if you
are working on your
SEO uh it can can be very useful to
create a website this way because the
content here will be rendered
immediately because it just static
content and there will be no JavaScript
that will run inside your website so for
SEO purpose it's amazing to use n
content also if you want to write some
kind of documentation or some kind of
blog you would use that because it's
easier to write here some content and to
use the Syntax for instance title syntax
of
markdown there we go as you see uh you
could you could be way faster by writing
here in uh MD file instead of uh working
in an HTML file let's create a new page
let's say that we're going to have some
kind of new file called profile. MD and
here I would like this is my profile
hello my name is Gam okay I'm going to
save this and now I'm going to go to
slash in profile and I type enter and
immediately my my root has been created
so of course this markdown is really
limited you cannot do any JavaScript or
very complicated stuff into it it's not
made to create web application really
it's more create to create some content
so another thing is that right now my
website is totally empty I would like to
get some to put some style I would like
to create
actually um some some just some design
you know I would like to add some colors
I would like to add some style etc etc
well what we could do is going back to
the no.com documentation and go to the
modules and what we could do we could
add Tailwind Tailwind as a module
instead of adding it directly from the
tailn documentation what I'm going to do
is to to install this Tailwind module so
I'm going to stop and I'm going to
install Tailwind as a module then I will
need to add it to my modules there so
I'm going to go to my next config and
actually next content is working exactly
like any other module as you see here
we've got n content that has been AED
and we've got TN CSS so you can either
create a n content application through
this NX content uh npx in it or you can
still add next conton to your existing
project okay so I've done this so now
I'm supposed to have tailin CSS
installed so now I'm going to type Yar
Dev there we go and if I get back to my
app I should have TN CSS that is apply
and there we go so now I got tawin CSS
what I can do is actually to inspect
okay my um my my markdown file that has
been transformed as an HTML and we see
see that here I got an H1 I got a
paragraph etc etc so what I can do is to
create my own design system I can right
click there create a new folder I'm
going to create an assets and in in this
I'm going to create a men. scss so what
I would do is to stop my server and to
type npm install
SAS and what I would do actually is just
to type yandev and I will add my SAS
here here file to my CSS inside my N.C
config dots so I'm going to type at
assets main. scss and I would save that
here what I would do is to import from
Tailwind my base and I would Target my
layer base which is actually the basic
layer that I'm using with Tailwind on my
application and what I would do I would
say hey I want that my H1 would be uh
apply text red 500 that's a color from
Tailwind so when I get back we see
suddenly that I got my title there and
exactly it would do the same on every
page okay so what I could do also is
just to put all this content so I can
get back to my Slug and here on the main
I could say that I want to put a
container MX Auto there so I would save
there we go and what I could do also I
could add some margin on the top and on
the bottom with
my4 and there we go so as you see now I
can create my own uh stylesheet my own
design system and then apply it to my
content everywhere in my application
again for the routing what I can do is
just to use the markdown so here on
about we see that I got a link let's go
on index and let's just remove this
let's say home and let's say that I want
have a link that would say go to
profile in with time/
profile there we go and I want to style
my link so I'm going to go here and say
that all links will have for instance a
color so text till uh yes let's say till
600 and underline whatever I'm going to
save that and there we go and when I
click I can uh go to the page I want
with the roting system if you want to
know more about next content you can go
on the documentation you can do that
with markdown with MDC syntax you can
also work with Jon as you see here you
can apply some Jon what you would do is
work on yaml also and you can work also
on the displaying on the rendering if
you have some questions about some stuff
that you would do you can go here and
look at rendering quer in navigation Etc
everything is provided a last thing if
you want to add some SEO to your page
because now you we are working with
markdown what you can do is at the top
of your file you can specify for
instance the title of your page so this
is my next content uh main page whatever
and when you get back here we see on the
top that I got this is my next content
main page so if you want to work on some
metas you can had them here on the top
and which is cool also with next content
is that it's really easy to deploy it's
really fast because it's just static
content that will be buil and
rendered we saw that with next content
we can create static website and we can
of course if we want create some
documentation for this practical
exercise that I propose you to end my
course on next what what I would like to
do is to create some kind of fake API
that we would request and next to it I
would like to create a fake
documentation okay so to do that I can
do entirely all these steps inside nree
because I can create my API with server
but of course I can also create my
documentation with n content however
when we start a n content project it's
empty there is no styling there's
nothing to do you have to build your own
style and actually with next what we can
do we can add our own teams and our
teams can be used to give some style to
a website if you look online you will
find some teams and actually we have one
and this one is used to make the website
of next content this team is creating
all this uh styling there and all this
website if we look at it quickly we will
find that this website is using the team
called docus docus that you can find at
docus dodev it's actually a team for
next that helps you to just install a a
documentation website a simple one this
way so it's really simple to use
actually but the thing is that you will
have a documentation with a sidebar and
everything already set up so you will
win a lot of time I'm going to start by
installing this team as a new
application at this point you should use
a specific version of node and if
possible the version 16 so me I'm going
to look by typing npm NV MLS sorry and
I'm going to use the 16
17.1 because the 18 there might be some
bug so here I'm going to say NVM use 16
17 one there we go and now what I'm
going to do I'm just going to copy paste
this to create my project and there we
go we got our docus that has been
initialized and if we take a look at it
a little bit we can see that it's a bit
different we've got some TS file
renovate dogson there's a bit of
different um uh configuration here but
actually it's still using next threee
with we can see on the dev dependencies
the next team docus so here we've got
our content what we're going to do we
are going to launch it right away so I'm
going to type Yan and yandev I got an
empty documentation that is available
with uh some specification I can turn it
to light and dark and I got this get
started and it's totally empty and we
can start writing a fake documentation
there so if I get back to the project I
got my next folder with this guide I got
yaml I got an index which is actually
the basic of my uh uh page and then I
got a folder and in with the folder
numbers to specify for my sidebar on
which side are going to be the um
documentation okay so what we could do
at first is just to start with our fake
uh API so here I'm going to call it
actually fake countries API okay API
there we go documentation so here on the
title here it's for the meta actually of
your project so I can go down and put
fake entries there so here it's marked
down again but we see it's a bit
difference uh is that we got a CTA
button where we can put the get started
uh uh code there and there's the link to
go to the guide or the button secondary
button then also on rset we can put
actually some uh code if we would like
to have some code so here I'm going to
write uh
um API to fetch any country in the world
with its name it's uh ID code and more
informations okay so I'm going to save
this and there we go I got my my title
there so now what is our API doing well
actually what we would like to do is to
have some end points so what I'm going
to start to do is to create a new folder
called server and in there I'm going to
create a subfolder called API because I
want to put API as a
prefix and in there let's say that I
would like to have a first endpoint
called random and it will be a random
endpoint an endpoint for random
countries so I'm going to create my
endpoint so export default which would
be a function and I'm going to return a
success true to try this thiso that
first so I'm going to get back and then
I'm going to type slash uh API SL random
and there we go okay my endpoint is
working that's great now what I want to
do I want to have some data that I would
use to um uh actually to display my
country or to answer by my country and I
found this amazing um Library by Dupo
called countries so I'm going to install
it so I'm going to stop actually my uh
server and I'm going to type Yan had at
Dupo that's the person who made it thank
you very much slash countries so I'm
going to type enter and it's going to
install for me this Library there we go
so I'm going to start again and there we
go and what I can do actually is to
import the countries or the country list
from the library so I'm going to get at
the top there there we go and I I think
country list should be an array so for
that I'm going just to consel country
list at first and let's look at it there
we go yeah there we go that's what I
thought we've got an array with some
countries there um I want that emplo to
be a get so I'm going to type random.
getet okay and it's going to change okay
that's right and what I want to answer
is actually a random country so I'm
going to type random country as an
answer and it's going to be country list
and inside the country is going to be a
matte floor matte random exactly country
list. length and there we go so let's
get back and let's try actually our
endpoint again and when I type enter
there we go I got jalar if I type again
aland
Island uh if I type again pu toico etc
etc okay that's cool it's working what I
could do now is actually to just create
the documentation about this endpoint so
I got API SL random so what I can do is
getting back on my fake countries API
I'm going to click on get started and
what I'm going to do at first is not to
remove this get started because I want
to keep it but actually I'm going to
create a uh in the guide actually in the
guide
section I'm going to oh maybe what can I
do is to create a second folder called
end points all right and if we save
nothing is happening here because what I
need to do is to create a dear. yaml
dear. yaml at the root and I'm I'm going
to use this uh as a as an example so I'm
going to copy paste this title guide and
I need to put a title so here um API
let's call it API all right so I'm going
to save okay nothing happens because I
need to put actually my zero.
index.md and this one let's let's take
the same example as we got there I'm
going to save and there we go as you see
I got my page that appeared there and
that which is cool is that we can see
that there is a navigation that is
automated um between the pages so API
and uh this one it's called get started
let's try to change the title there so
I'm going to remove this and let's say
get a uh random uh country and we see
now that my title is now appearing on my
sidebar so I'm going to get back and I'm
going to type some documentation about
it so here it's again markdown so you
can write whatever you want and point to
get a random country on our countryes
list okay so what we could do also is to
to type some code that we could put here
what I can put is Method get and down
there I could put / API SL random and
I'm going to save and as we see there we
go we've got our random that is here and
point to get a random country on our
country list you want to know more about
creating endpoints with Nitro you can go
on the official documentation of nr. ns.
nitro can exist by himself also it right
now we are using it in n3e but you can
also create regular endpoints with Nal
so what we're going to do now we are
going to create a new endpoint where
we're going to post actually a request
with a string and we want to find in our
array of countries the specific country
so what I'm going to do I'm going to get
back to my app and in the API folder I'm
going to create a new folder called
countries and there I'm going to create
a new endpoint called um find. poost
dots find would be just the endpoint so
it will be actually um API SL countries
slind okay and this endpoint will be a
method post all right so what I'm going
to do I'm going to use uh the example of
nitro and it's exactly the same as the
random one the difference is that I
didn't use the event handler here
function it's exactly the same but
whatever okay so now we return user
profile it's going to be an object that
we will return at the end and what we
want to do actually is to use the
country list that we had before so I'm
going to come back on this and I'm going
to import actually my country list and
there we go so what I want to do is to
post as a
body uh actually I'm going to
post an object with inside and there
will be uh We call we can call that
country okay and Country tree will be a
string okay so um I'm just making those
notes for this course and don't take
them as a good practice uh most of the
time you have better way to write
comments in API this course is not about
back end either on API it's just to show
you the example so it will be a string
country will be a string and we will
catch it through this event so what
we're going to do is to create a
variable called body and we want towait
for a function a native function of nro
and this native function is read body
rbody we pass the event to it and it
going to return for us directly our body
as an object which is very cool so we
will get our country up there so once I
got the country I can destructure
country from the
body and here what I can do is to return
uh the countries that we will will find
with this string so for instance here if
I'm going to type France is going to
return to me here anray with countries
that correspond to France so there's two
things that I need to do I need to look
at how country lists are looking at and
here I get to return countries it's not
specifically one country it's not fine
one country it's it may be several
countries because we will see that our
string will match the letters and in
there what I'm going to do uh I think I
already know but I'm going just to put
true for now and I'm going to look at
the list and there we go I want to match
the label okay I want to match the label
with country so if it's going to be
Ghana in my country here I want to match
the label in my array so I'm going to do
country list simple JavaScript then I'm
going to filter and what I want to do is
that here I got an object and in this
subject I want to match my object. label
that we just saw and I just want to know
if it's going to
include if it's going to include
actually country all right so we can
save this I'm going to remove that and
now I need to post to this end point to
know if I get some response to do that
me I'm using actually rapid API rapid
API help you to create some uh uh
actually it's Postman inside your um IDE
and here especially it's Visual Studio
code so here I need to create a new uh
call and this new call actually would be
my post so I'm going to go there I'm
going to post to what I'm going to post
to uh
actually HTTP 2 loal host
3,000 SL API countries and here it's
find okay so I'm going to click on Jon
and here I'm going to pass my country
okay and let's say that we are going to
type France okay and when I type send
there we go we see that I have my
country that have been found on my
endpoint which is API countries
slind okay now let's say that I want to
remove some letters on my country down
there let's say that I want just to type
fra it's still going to find friends
because on my uh endpoint I'm just
filtering on includes uh the strings and
I'm looking at labels so I'm going to
get back and if I remove some letters I
got more countries that start actually
with uh French actually French Gana
France French Polynesia French s etc etc
now if I type an a I'm going to get back
and I'm to click on s here I got several
countries so these several countries are
Algeria American Sam Andora Angola
angila etc etc you're not obliged to use
Rapid API for this course you can use
for instance Postman it's better but for
me uh I got this in my vs code it's
faster now I have created my endpoint
what I want to do I want to put the
documentation to use it so I'm going to
get back there in my index and what I
can write here it's find a country by
label uh and actually it's going to be
exactly the same find a country by label
on our list it's going to be a post and
this time it's going to be countries SL
find and if I save and I get back I
update we see that there's a problem
because I got my index and it it doesn't
put here find a country by label so what
I need to do is actually to create
create another page what I need to do if
I want to separate the two files I can
create another markdown file
1.5mg for instance and I arrived there
with my uh explanation and there we go
we see that I got get a random country
find a country by label and there we go
of course this presentation is not very
well I should work more on the design on
what I want to do so here we see that we
can copy paste the code which is
amazing however we've got this method
get on the top it should not be here so
I going to remove this and I got my end
point okay and I'm going to put just end
point there so it makes me think that I
have to change my uh uh my description
up there and what I could do is instead
of putting this what I could put is my
method get there okay so I would have
method get as a reference up there of
course I'm not a big boss in markdown
I'm sure you you got a lot of ways of
doing nicer stuff but that should be
enough so I got my end point okay here
and actually I can remove in point and
what I would like to have is a response
example so I'm going to take this and
remember on my API random I have a
response so what I can do is just to
type SL API random looking at a response
and I'm just going to copy paste this as
an example so I'm going to get back and
I'm going to update okay and here in my
response I'm going to put my fake
response and there we go that's an
example of a good documentation we could
do so what I'm going to do I'm going to
uh copy paste actually the same model so
I'm going to get back on find and
instead of having this uh method on the
top I would put method post okay and I
would put for instance a response
example down there and actually I can
take back this I'm going to go there and
the response that I get so let's get
back on my API call which I got
here here exactly here I got a response
and I'm going to put friends I'm going
to type and there we go now I can copy
paste this here and I got some kind of
response there and look at this so
that's really cool really quickly I
succeed to create the base of an API and
actually at the same time the base of a
documentation however if we look closely
at what we do we put the Endo we put the
response but we didn't put the body so
let's get back on our find a country by
label and and what I'm going to do is on
the top of response I'm going to put a
body example so I'm going just copy
paste this and on the body of course I
got to pass the country which will be of
course France and here what I can
specify is that it will be a string okay
so here I got a string with the body and
that's good we are good uh another thing
that we would like to do is to find
countries by language and that could be
amazing so we should look first at our
endpoint and we should look at actually
um actually we should look at the
countries that we've got Okay so we've
got a countries there and these
countries they should have uh a language
so as we see on the model on typescript
we already saw that there's a language
which would be an array containing
strings that's amazing later we will be
able to create a currency and also to
work on a code capital or stuff that we
want all right so we're going to work on
these languages at first and we want to
create an endpoint with languages and we
suddenly realize that our countries
doind it's a bit weird Okay as an
endpoint because find would mean
anything and in our documentation we can
see that we can find a country by label
okay so and and and our titles are very
long also so if we would like to do
something more clear we would have to
work on our API uh endpoint and we will
have to work on our names all right I
improved a bit this documentation and I
created some m points and let me present
them to you now so we still have this
entry here with this uh stuff that is is
useless actually I should change it and
it's called fake countries so I don't
know why it's called fake countries I
should have put countries because it's
still real countries so when we click on
get started we arrive on the guide that
I worked on so basically I've haded
welcome on fake countries API I've haded
version the date how to use it and the
options that we can have if we look at
the documentation of um docus actually
we've had um some options that we can
add such as check danger and stuff
that's really interesting I've added
some rules this API is free to use
however please do not spam or use it
more than one other times per day we
banish your IP for 30 days if you spam
it yeah that's what I wrote there's an
about section and we see here on the
right actually that we've got a sub
content um panel that is really useful
on the actual uh on the actual page and
on my API I've worked on my endpoints so
I try to be very very uh concise and
very clear about what the API is doing
so what I did actually I've created an
endpoint called get all and here we've
got this end point this is API country
Hall so we don't need anybody so what
I'm going to do I'm going to test
actually on my Local Host descent point
and there we go let's look at this we
have the full file actually as a GS uh a
gson file actually sorry about every
country and everything we've got on it
that's really cool okay that's the
endpoint that I've created and I've keep
this model of putting the method and a
short description and the endpoint and
an example of what we can have so it can
be very useful if you want to use the
flag the name the code of whatever then
I've worked on the uh random one so as
you see now we've got API SL countries
slash uh uh the the the name of the end
point that we're going to have so for
all I get SL all for random I put slash
random so when we get back to the server
now we've got our server with the API
because there is another route that I'm
going to show you after and on API I got
a folder countries with all.get because
it's a get and random that it's a get
also and what I'm do actually when I get
an object I'm transforming into an array
and then I look at it so basically we've
got all the end points there that will
be with this API SL countries so here
I'm going to try my random endpoint and
there we go I got a random country there
then after on the other methods by label
by Capital by
currency these are post and on those
post actually I'm returning Not Gon I'm
returning Anor so basically here we've
got label so we're going to try it I'm
going to try to catch a country by label
um so I'm going to get back there on my
um uh previous post and I'm going to
type HTTP SL Local Host 3,000 then with
my slash so I'm going just to push that
this way I'm going to get back there and
when I send it there we go I got friend
if I try to find United something for
instance United there we go I got United
Arab Emirates United Kingdom United
States so my endpoint label. poost dots
is working and also what I did on my
endpoints is that I put some guards so
here I got my guards on the label all
right right uh I did the same with
currency I did the same with capital so
let's try Capital so I'm going to go on
the documentation get by Capital what I
can do is to find a country by its
capital so I'm going to type instead of
countries here capital and here as
capital I'm going to pass uh for
instance
Washington and when I'm going to send it
there we go I got the countries by
Capital which is
amazing um what I can do also is to type
by currency and currency is interesting
because here with currency I will have
several other countries so when I type
for the Euro I got all the countries of
Europe that have the Euro as a currency
um let me try to find a doll for ah no
it's not yeah it's working well it's not
do it's USD so there we go we see all
the countries that are using USD for
instance so what I did it's exactly the
same I just copied paste some code and
it's working very good if there is no
currency we can see that we got also an
error and it's working very well so now
you can go on the documentation and
check all of this was a quick course to
teach you how to use next content and
how to use all the force of next to
create an API and to create a
documentation of course we could have
done it by creating a full stack
application also it would have worked
however it would have take a lot of time
to create the own design actually the
whole template instead using docus
helped us a lot so this is a good
example on how you could create a
business for instance if you would like
to create an API where people could
fetch some data
you would had to this a stripe layer to
make people pay and to be able to use
the API by once they pay they get a
token and they can use this token and
you could do a lot of stuff like this so
this is really not a real documentation
okay this is a start to end this listen
I wanted to show you where I found docus
actually I went on next team here on
next team what you can see is that you
have several different team that you
could apply to your NS application so
we've got dcus which is here and this is
the one that I use that help us to
create a documentation on the Fly
however you got some other uh teams that
you could use and I think in the future
there will be more and more teams that
will be a available under next free not
pretending that I can build a whole
documentation by myself and I'm not
pretending that I'm an awesome backend
developer but this was a good example to
show you how we can use next and how we
can use its power to create a full
documentation and a full stack
application so what I would do now my
documentation is online I would deploy
it on netlify or versal and right away
what would happen is that my endpoints
would be available on the address
provided by netlify and versa
and congratulation you succeed to create
your first documentation and your first
full stack application with nuggs thank
you very much for watching this entire
video I hope it helped you to create a
full stack application see you next time
bye